This episode is brought to you by Lloyds, which has been backing British ambition for over 250 years. Now, when you think about it, every dynasty in history has boiled down to two important elements, aspiration and action. And a classic example of this from British history, the rise of the House of Wessex, the family of Alfred the Great and his heirs, who between them established the United Kingdom of England. Yeah, it's a great story, isn't it, Tom? A great lesson in leadership, I think, for anybody. So Alfred and his heirs, they marry idealism and pragmatism.
本期节目由劳埃德银行赞助播出，该银行已支持英国雄心壮志超过250年。说起来，历史上每一个王朝归根结底都离不开两个重要元素：抱负与行动。英国历史上一个典型的例子就是威塞克斯王朝的崛起，即阿尔弗雷德大帝及其继承人的家族，他们共同建立了英格兰联合王国。是的，这是一个伟大的故事，对吧，汤姆？我认为这对任何人来说都是一堂很好的领导力课程。所以，阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人将理想主义与实用主义结合在了一起。
They're brilliant at alliances. They're brilliant at managing power. They're brilliance, of course, at managing their money, which is a key part of political leadership. And, of course, we are all reaping the rewards of their wisdom and foresight. When it's time to make your next move, you can bank on Lloyds to be ready. when you are. Because from new businesses to new homes and new life chapters, backed by generations
他们擅长结盟，擅长驾驭权力。当然，他们也擅长理财，这是政治领导力的关键部分。当然，我们都在享受他们智慧和远见的成果。当您需要做出下一个决策时，您可以信赖劳埃德银行，随时为您准备。因为从新企业到新家园，再到人生的新篇章，在几代人的支持下，
of hope and ambition, you can see, Tom, why 14 million people trust Lloyds to help make their dreams a reality. Based on Lloyd's internal customer data from March 26. A report of the capture and torching of Sardis by the Athenians and Ionians was brought to King Darius. It is said that the King's initial response to this news was to dismiss the Ionians as being of no account, since he knew full well that they had no prospect of escaping retribution for their insurgency. But the Athenians he did ask after. And on being told who they were, he asked for his bow. and when he had it he fitted an arrow, which he then fired into the heavens.
怀揣着希望与抱负，汤姆，你就能明白为什么1400万人信任劳埃德银行，帮助他们实现梦想。基于劳埃德银行2026年3月26日的内部客户数据。关于雅典人和爱奥尼亚人占领并焚烧萨迪斯的消息被传到了大流士国王耳中。据说，国王最初对这一消息的反应是认为爱奥尼亚人不足为虑，因为他深知他们无法逃脱因叛乱而受到的惩罚。但他确实打听了雅典人的情况。当得知他们是谁时，他要来了自己的弓，搭上一支箭，然后射向天空。
And even as he sent it winging through the air, so he cried, Zeus, do not deny me the chance to punish the Athenians. Having made this appeal, he ordered one of his servants to repeat to him three times whenever a meal was set before him. Master, remember the Athenians. The year is 498 BC. We are in Persia, in Iran, at the court of the Persian King of Kings. And this is the ancient world's answer to that moment, which we've all seen, when George W. Bush is being told about 9-11, when he's reading to those schoolchildren. It's the moment when the most powerful man on the earth hears about a devastating attack that seems to have come absolutely out of night.
就在箭划过天空时，他大喊道：“宙斯，请不要剥夺我惩罚雅典人的机会。”发出这一呼吁后，他命令一名仆人在每次进餐时都要向他重复三遍：“主人，记住雅典人。”那是公元前498年。我们身处波斯，在伊朗，在波斯万王之王的宫廷里。这就是古代世界对那个时刻的回应，我们都见过那个场景：乔治·W·布什在给小学生读书时得知了9·11事件。那是地球上最有权势的人听到一场似乎完全出乎意料的毁灭性袭击的时刻。
nowhere by a group of people whom he regards as terrorists. And Tom, this is from the ancient historian Herodotus, isn't it? Translated by me, and I thought you rendered it beautifully, especially the hint of the eunuch in the servant. Thank you. I was thinking it was a worm tongue thing going on with that servant. No, it was very good. Yeah, so Herodotus, the first historian, and his great work takes as its theme, the story of how the Persian Empire in the early decades of the 5th century BC, tries to conquer Greece and ultimately fails. And what Herodotus is giving us in that passage is the moment when the Persian invasions of Greece become inevitable. It's the kind of key turning point in the drama of his great story.
这群人被他视为恐怖分子。汤姆，这是出自古代历史学家希罗多德的著作，对吧？由我翻译，我觉得你翻译得非常优美，尤其是仆人身上那种太监的暗示。谢谢。我当时觉得那个仆人有点像《指环王》里的“巧言”。不，这非常好。是的，希罗多德是第一位历史学家，他的伟大著作以公元前5世纪初波斯帝国试图征服希腊并最终失败的故事为主题。希罗多德在这一段中展现的是波斯入侵希腊变得不可避免的时刻。这是他宏大叙事中关键的转折点。
So what is going on here? The Athenians have crossed from Greece. They've crossed the Aegean and they have joined forces with other Greeks called the Ionians who live on what is now the Eegean coastline of Turkey, and they are subjects of the Persian king, because of course they are in Asia, and the Persians lay claim to the rule of Asia. Or at least they had been subjects of the Persian king,
那么这里发生了什么？雅典人从希腊出发，跨越爱琴海，与生活在现今土耳其爱琴海沿岸、被称为爱奥尼亚人的其他希腊人联手。他们是波斯国王的臣民，因为他们当然身处亚洲，而波斯人声称拥有亚洲的统治权。或者至少他们曾经是波斯国王的臣民，
because actually they have risen in rebellion, and the Athenians have been persuaded by the Ionian leader to join them in this insurrection, and they've marched inland from the Aegean coast with the Ionians, and they've attacked the great city of Sardis, which is the capital of the Persian governor, who kind of administers the region for the great king. And the Persian governor retreats to the Acropolis, so the kind of the upper fortress of Sardis and holds out there, the Athenians and the Ionians can't capture that.
因为实际上他们已经起义了，雅典人在爱奥尼亚领袖的劝说下加入了这场叛乱。他们与爱奥尼亚人一起从爱琴海沿岸向内陆进军，袭击了萨迪斯大城，那是波斯总督的驻地，总督为万王之王管理该地区。波斯总督撤退到了卫城，也就是萨迪斯的上层堡垒并坚守在那里，雅典人和爱奥尼亚人无法攻克。
But they are able to capture the rest of the city and they torch it. Everything goes up in flames, including one of the most famous buildings in the whole of the Persian Empire. And this is a temple to Kibelae, the mother goddess. Oh yeah, a friend of the show. Very much friend of the show. A great fan of blood weddings and mass castrations and so on. And obviously, this is the equivalent of people flying planes into the Twin Towers. I mean, this is an appalling insult and appalling affront.
但他们能够占领城市的其余部分并将其焚毁。一切都化为灰烬，包括整个波斯帝国最著名的建筑之一。这是一座献给大地女神库柏勒的神庙。哦，是的，节目的老朋友。非常老的朋友。血腥婚礼和大规模阉割等等的忠实粉丝。显然，这相当于有人驾驶飞机撞向双子塔。我的意思是，这是一种令人震惊的侮辱和令人震惊的冒犯。
And there is no way that Darius, the Great King, cannot respond to it. I mean, in much the same way that George W. Bush felt that he had to respond to 9-11. And in this episode and the next, we will be looking at what his. response was. So it's a really gripping, I mean, extraordinary story. Yeah, so we're going to be looking at how the Persians try to suppress the Ionian revolt, how they send this extraordinary amphibious operation across the Aegean with orders to destroy the city of Athens and to bring its people back as slaves. The Persians end up landing on a plane near Athens called Marathon, and then a battle is fought at Marathon. One way or another, it is from that battle that
大流士作为万王之王，绝不可能不做出回应。我的意思是，就像乔治·W·布什觉得他必须对9·11做出回应一样。在本集和下一集中，我们将探讨他的回应是什么。所以这是一个非常引人入胜，我的意思是，非凡的故事。是的，我们将探讨波斯人如何试图镇压爱奥尼亚起义，他们如何派遣这支非凡的两栖部队跨越爱琴海，命令摧毁雅典城并将雅典人民作为奴隶带回。波斯人最终在雅典附近的一个平原登陆，那里叫马拉松，随后在马拉松爆发了一场战役。不管怎样，正是从那场战役中，
we get the marathon, don't we? What a lovely fact that is. So let's begin with our protagonist, who is not a Greek, but a Persian. He is the great king, the king of kings, and he is, so Darius is by far the most powerful man on earth at this point. I mean, he is the most powerful man who has ever lived. I think it's no exaggeration at this point to say that. So, yeah, he's got these incredible titles, Great King, King of Kings, King of King, King of Kings, King of of lands. You know, he's essentially an Iranian patriot. So he describes himself in his inscriptions as being a Persian, the son of a Persian. He's very proud of that. As a person, he is the lord of a people who essentially in the course of a single lifetime have gone from provincial obscurity
我们才有了马拉松，不是吗？这是一个多么可爱的历史事实。那么让我们从我们的主角开始，他不是希腊人，而是波斯人。他是万王之王，他是大流士，此时他是地球上无可争议的最强大的人。我的意思是，他是历史上最强大的人。我认为此时这样说并不夸张。所以，是的，他拥有这些令人难以置信的头衔：万王之王，众王之王，万国之王。你知道，他本质上是一位伊朗爱国者。他在铭文中称自己为波斯人，波斯人的儿子。他对此感到非常自豪。作为一个个体，他是一个民族的领袖，这个民族在短短的一生中，从省级的默默无闻，
to becoming the rulers of the greatest empire that the world has ever seen. And under Darius, it stretches from the Aegean all the way to the Hindu Kush and the Indus. And the man who had won the Persians, this great empire. He's a man who we have already met in the rest of history this year. And that is Cyrus the Great, because Dominic, the Shah of Iran, as in Jimmy Carter, was a big fan of Cyrus the Great, wasn't he? He did. He had a party.
变成了世界上见过的最伟大帝国的统治者。在大流士统治下，帝国从爱琴海一直延伸到兴都库什山脉和印度河。而那个为波斯赢得这个伟大帝国的人，就是我们今年在《历史的其余部分》中已经见过的人。那就是居鲁士大帝，因为多米尼克，伊朗的沙阿，就像吉米·卡特一样，是居鲁士大帝的忠实粉丝，不是吗？他确实是。他举办了一场派对。
I think a party that occurred more than once on the rest of history or been covered more than once, because it was one of history's most disastrous parties. So he held this huge blowout in 1971 to celebrate. what they claimed was the 2,500th anniversary of the founding of the Persian Empire. What the Shah wanted to do in the 1960s and 70s was to lay claim to the heritage of Cyrus and to say he is a new Cyrus building Persia up, you know, from nothing to become a genuine superpower. And Cyrus, unlike the Shah, was a really, really serious person, wasn't he?
我想这场派对在《历史的其余部分》中不止一次出现，或者被报道过不止一次，因为它是有史以来最灾难性的派对之一。他在1971年举办了这场盛大的狂欢，以庆祝他们声称的波斯帝国建立2500周年。沙阿在20世纪60年代和70年代想要做的是宣称拥有居鲁士的遗产，并说他是一位新的居鲁士，从零开始建设波斯，使其成为一个真正的超级大国。而居鲁士与沙阿不同，他是一个非常、非常严肃的人，不是吗？
I mean, he was the great empire builder, arguably in all history, the prototypical empire builder. Yeah, so he dies in 529 BC, before that he'd ruled for three decades. And over the course of that reign, he enjoys one of the greatest winning streaks in the whole of history. So he's up there with Alexander, Julia Caesar, one of the greats. And he topples a succession of famous and ancient empires. So the first empire that he topples is the empire of the Meads. and they occupy kind of north-west Iran, so Tehran would be in what was media. And the Persians had been subjects to the Medes.
我的意思是，他是伟大的帝国建设者，可以说是历史上所有帝国建设者的原型。是的，他死于公元前529年，在此之前他统治了三十年。在那段统治期间，他享受了历史上最伟大的连胜纪录之一。所以他与亚历山大、尤利乌斯·凯撒并列，是伟大的领袖之一。他推翻了一连串著名而古老的帝国。他推翻的第一个帝国是米底帝国，他们占据了伊朗西北部，所以德黑兰就在米底境内。而波斯人曾经是米底人的臣民。
So the Persians actually see the Medes as cousins. And when they conquer the Medes, they essentially incorporate the Medes in as kind of junior partners in the entire enterprise of running this empire. And to the Greeks, the Persians and the Medes are indistinguishable. They're likely to refer to the Persians as Medes. So if you hear Meads in this, it's kind of Meads and Persians. So Cyrus, he's now got the Meads on board. Then he marches eastwards into what is now Turkey, so Anatolia.
所以波斯人实际上把米底人视为表亲。当他们征服米底人时，他们本质上将米底人作为管理这个帝国的整个事业中的初级合伙人纳入其中。对于希腊人来说，波斯人和米底人是无法区分的。他们很可能把波斯人称为米底人。所以如果你在这里听到米底人，它有点像“米底人和波斯人”。所以居鲁士，他现在已经把米底人纳入麾下。然后他向东进军到现在的土耳其，也就是安纳托利亚。
And he attacks a city we've already heard of, Sardis. And this is the capital of the Lydians. And the Lydians are a very prosperous, wealthy power. They have subjected the Ionian Greeks on the Aegean shore to their rule. And the source of their power is their ability to monetize their power. And they've literally monetized it because they've invented money. And this is why the last king, Cresus, who gets defeated by Cyrus, overthrown by him, you know, he's still a byword, you're rich as Cresis. You know, you're fabulously, fabulously rich.
他袭击了我们已经听说过的一座城市，萨迪斯。这是吕底亚人的首都。吕底亚人是一个非常繁荣、富有的强权。他们统治着爱琴海沿岸的爱奥尼亚希腊人。他们权力的源泉在于他们将权力货币化的能力。他们确实将其货币化了，因为他们发明了货币。这就是为什么被居鲁士击败并推翻的最后一位国王克罗伊斯，至今仍是富有的代名词，“像克罗伊斯一样富有”。你知道，富得流油。
So now the Lydians have been toppled and with the defeat of the Lydians, the Ionians also come under the rule of the Persians. Right. And just to remind people, this is modern day Turkey, basically, that we're talking about. That's Anatolia is now subject to the Persians as well as media. And this leaves perhaps the greatest power of all to be conquered, and this is Babylon, you know, this fabulous ancient city, the richer city in the world. And Cyrus conquers that in 539. And Herodotus gives a brilliant estimation of just how vast Babylon was. He writes, according to local tradition, such was the size of the city that those who lived in the centre of Babylon had no idea when the Persians broke into the city that the suburbs had fallen, for it was a time of festival and all were dancing and indulging
所以现在吕底亚人被推翻了，随着吕底亚人的失败，爱奥尼亚人也处于波斯人的统治之下。没错。提醒一下大家，我们谈论的基本上是今天的土耳其。安纳托利亚现在和米底一样，都受波斯人统治。这留下了也许是最强大的力量等待被征服，那就是巴比伦，你知道，这座美妙的古城，世界上最富有的城市。居鲁士在公元前539年征服了它。希罗多德对巴比伦的广阔程度做出了精彩的估计。他写道，根据当地传统，城市规模之大，以至于住在巴比伦中心的人们在波斯人破城而入时，根本不知道郊区已经沦陷，因为当时正值节日，所有人都沉浸在舞蹈和享乐中。
themselves in pleasures. And for Cyrus, the conquest of Babylon is what sets the seal on his ascent to greatness. So there's a slightly kind of Trumpian quality to his boasting of his inscriptions. He proclaims every king on earth brought me heavy tribute and kissed my feet where I sat in Babylon. So he's made it. So to give people just a sense, just if you think about looking at the map, we are talking about an empire that started in modern day Iran and that has swallowed up. Iraq, which is where Babylon effectively was. That's right, isn't it, Tom? And Anatolia, which is sort of inland Turkey, and has also taken the Turkish coast, which is inhabited by Greek speakers. So it is a vast empire. And also has conquered what would now be Syria and Israel and Lebanon,
对于居鲁士来说，征服巴比伦是他登上伟大巅峰的印记。所以他的铭文吹嘘中有一种特朗普式的特质。他宣称：“地球上的每一位国王都向我进贡重礼，并在我坐在巴比伦时亲吻我的脚。”所以他成功了。为了让大家有个概念，如果你看地图，我们谈论的是一个始于现代伊朗的帝国，它吞并了伊拉克，也就是巴比伦实际上所在的地方。那是对的，不是吗，汤姆？还有安纳托利亚，也就是内陆土耳其，也占领了土耳其海岸，那里居住着讲希腊语的人。所以这是一个庞大的帝国。而且还征服了现在的叙利亚、以色列和黎巴嫩，
because they were subject to Babylon, so they come under Cyrus's rule. And indeed, is eyeing up Egypt, am I right? So Cyrus doesn't attack Egypt. He goes off, into Central Asia, and that's where he reaches the Indus, he reaches the Hindu Kush, he goes even further, and that's where he's killed. His son has eyes up Egypt, Cambyses, right? His son, yes. So, so when Cyrus dies fighting in Central Asia in 529, he leaves behind him two sons. And the first of these, you just mentioned, Cambyses, he becomes the new King of Kings. But Cyrus also has a younger son called Bardia, and Bardia is entrusted with the rule of the Eastern Satrapes, the Eastern Prophes, the eastern provinces, as they're called.
因为它们曾是巴比伦的臣民，所以它们处于居鲁士的统治之下。而且，确实在觊觎埃及，我没说错吧？所以居鲁士没有攻击埃及。他去了中亚，那是他到达印度河、兴都库什山脉的地方，他走得更远，并在那里被杀。他的儿子觊觎埃及，冈比西斯，对吧？他的儿子，是的。所以，当居鲁士在公元前529年中亚作战时去世，他留下了两个儿子。第一个就是你刚才提到的冈比西斯，他成为了新的万王之王。但居鲁士还有一个小儿子叫巴尔迪亚，巴尔迪亚被委托统治东部总督辖区，也就是所谓的东部省份。
And it's obvious that Cyrus is very keen to ensure that the rule of the world remains within the family. So to ensure that kind of rival nobles can't get in on the act, Cambysius has married both his sisters. And this is an unprecedented display of incest. There's nothing in Persian custom that would license that. But Cyrus, Cambysi's Bardia, you know, they want it to remain a kind of family concern. And this is obviously bad news for even distant cousins of the Persian royal family. And one of these distant cousins is Darius, who when Cambyses becomes king is still in his 20s.
很明显，居鲁士非常渴望确保世界统治权留在家族内部。为了确保竞争对手的贵族无法参与其中，冈比西斯娶了他的两个姐妹。这是一种前所未有的乱伦表现。波斯习俗中没有任何东西可以许可这一点。但居鲁士、冈比西斯、巴尔迪亚，你知道，他们希望这保持为一种家族事务。这对于波斯王室的远房表亲来说显然是个坏消息。其中一位远房表亲就是大流士，当冈比西斯成为国王时，他才20多岁。
And he is the lance bearer to Cambyses, which might sound a slightly menial function, but it doesn't because it indicates that essentially he's playing the role of a personal bodyguard. and proximity to the monarch in Persia is a kind of indicator of status. So actually it's a very kind of splendid honorific. I mean, it marks you out as certainly a kind of major player at court, even if you're not a royal. And it enables Darius clearly to be privy to very, very sensitive royal secrets. He's got his finger on the pulse. He knows what's going on. And that is what enables him in the summer of 522.
他是冈比西斯的持矛侍卫，这听起来可能是一个稍微卑微的职能，但事实并非如此，因为它表明他本质上扮演的是私人保镖的角色。在波斯，接近君主是一种地位的象征。所以实际上这是一个非常辉煌的荣誉头衔。我的意思是，它标志着你肯定是一位宫廷中的重要人物，即使你不是皇室成员。它使大流士能够清楚地获悉非常、非常敏感的皇室秘密。他掌握着脉搏。他知道发生了什么。而这正是使他在公元前522年夏天，
when the dynasty of Cyrus abruptly implodes to have a very good idea of what is going on and to know how to respond. So the account that we have comes from Darius himself and how much of it is true is impossible to say. But it basically begins with Cambysi's going mad, doesn't he? He goes mad and he becomes incredibly jealous of Bardia and has him put to death. So far, so standard kind of Game of Thrones style was the Roses fraternal jealousy. But now there's a tremendous twist, which I'm looking forward to hearing you explain. So tell us what happens next. So Bardia has been killed on the orders of Cambyses, who is still kind of whooping it up in Egypt, which he's just conquered.
当居鲁士王朝突然崩溃时，能够非常清楚地了解正在发生的事情并知道如何应对的原因。所以我们拥有的叙述来自大流士本人，其中有多少是真实的无法说清。但它基本上始于冈比西斯发疯，不是吗？他疯了，对巴尔迪亚变得极其嫉妒，并下令将他处死。到目前为止，这还是标准的《权力的游戏》式的兄弟嫉妒。但现在有一个巨大的转折，我很期待听你解释。所以告诉我们接下来发生了什么。所以巴尔迪亚在冈比西斯的命令下被杀，冈比西斯当时还在埃及狂欢，他刚刚征服了那里。
The twist is that Bardia is now replaced in the eastern provinces by someone who looks exactly like Bardia. but isn't. So the magi are the kind of the Persian equivalent of the Brahmins. They're like a kind of priestly cast. And this kind of fake megas, I mean by amazing coincidence, he exactly resembles Bardia. And this fake Bardia then stages a rebellion against Cambyses. The news is brought to Cambyses in Egypt. He's furious, of course. He leaps on his horse, leads an expedition out of Egypt through Syria. And in Syria, he pauses, has some food, and then he's climbing up onto his horse, and his sword accidentally slips, and he stabs himself in the thigh with it. And this wound then goes septic, and he dies very shortly afterwards. So that's Cambyses out of the way. And at this point,
转折是，巴尔迪亚现在在东部省份被一个长得和巴尔迪亚一模一样的人取代了。但那个人不是他。所以“玛吉”是波斯版的婆罗门。他们就像一种祭司阶层。而这个假玛吉，我的意思是，巧合的是，他长得和巴尔迪亚一模一样。然后这个假巴尔迪亚对冈比西斯发动了叛乱。消息传到了在埃及的冈比西斯耳中。他当然很愤怒。他跳上马，带领一支远征军从埃及穿过叙利亚。在叙利亚，他停下来吃了一些食物，然后他爬上马背，他的剑意外滑落，他用剑刺伤了自己的大腿。这个伤口随后感染，他不久后就去世了。所以冈比西斯就这样出局了。在这一点上，
the false Magus, the kind of the pretend Bardia, declares that he is now king of kings. And the only people who know the truth that this isn't really Bardia is Darius and six other nobleman. And they get together a posse and they gallop from Syria across the kind of the parched flatlands of Mesopotamia, up the Corazon Highway, which is the road that sneaks up through the Zagros Mountains up towards the great plateau of Iran. And they arrive at a place called Sikkia Vautish, which is up in the heights of the Zagros Mountains, surrounded by rich fields. there are famous horses from these fields so it's a kind of beautiful spot
那个假玛吉，那个假巴尔迪亚，宣布他现在是万王之王。唯一知道真相的人，即这不是真正的巴尔迪亚，是大流士和其他六位贵族。他们召集了一支队伍，从叙利亚疾驰穿过美索不达米亚干旱的平原，沿着呼罗珊公路，那是穿过扎格罗斯山脉通往伊朗大高原的道路。他们到达了一个叫西基亚沃蒂什的地方，它位于扎格罗斯山脉的高处，周围是肥沃的田野。这些田野里有著名的马匹，所以这是一个美丽的地方。
and Bardia is or rather the fake Bardia is hanging out there enjoying his concubines when Darius the six other nobleman and the kind of posse of men they've brought burst in on him take the fake Bardia completely by surprise he reaches for a chair smashes it up
巴尔迪亚，或者说假巴尔迪亚，正待在那里享受他的妃子，这时大流士、其他六位贵族以及他们带来的队伍冲了进去，完全出其不意地抓住了假巴尔迪亚。他伸手去拿一把椅子，把它砸碎，
tries to use the chair leg to fend them off it's no good he is dispatched and Darius then proclaims to the world that there's you know there's been this terrible scam that Bardi had been replaced by this false Magus and that he is now the king. Quite deep waters, I think. Quite a lot of improbabilities there. Yeah. You don't have to be a tremendous skeptic to think that actually what was happening was that he had planned a coup himself and he organizes the murder
试图用椅腿抵挡他们，但这没用，他被处决了。大流士随后向世界宣布，你知道，发生了一场可怕的骗局，巴尔迪亚被这个假玛吉取代了，而他现在是国王。我认为水很深。那里有很多不可思议的事情。是的。你不必是一个巨大的怀疑论者就会认为，实际上发生的事情是他自己策划了一场政变，他组织了谋杀
of these two brothers, right? Yeah, because I think the sword in the thigh accident. Come on. That's, yeah, he accidentally stabbed yourself in the thigh with it. Yeah. And even that's not a as improbable as the idea that, you know, there's a guy who looks exactly like the murdered king. So I think the likelihood is there isn't a false Bardia, there isn't a kind of mey and that the person who gets killed by Darius and his fellow conspirators in Sikyavoutish was actually Bardia himself. And there's very good corroborating evidence for this because the moment Darius announces his accession to the throne, there is a succession of rebellions and these take place in Persia itself, in media just to the north, and in Elam,
这两个兄弟，对吧？是的，因为我认为大腿上的剑伤事故。得了吧。那是，是的，他意外地用剑刺伤了自己的大腿。是的。甚至这也不如“有一个长得和被谋杀的国王一模一样的人”的想法那么不可思议。所以我认为可能性是，根本没有假巴尔迪亚，没有所谓的玛吉，大流士和他的同谋在西基亚沃蒂什杀死的实际上就是巴尔迪亚本人。而且有非常好的佐证，因为大流士宣布他继位的那一刻，就发生了一连串的叛乱，这些叛乱发生在波斯本土、北部的米底，以及埃兰，
which is a country in the southwest of Iran. So basically, these are the absolute heartlands of the empire. These are the kind of, you know, the Iranian strongholds. And clearly in these Iranian strongholds, they are viewing Darius as a, as an illegitimate king. And it takes him two years of desperate fighting to crush these rebellions. And even once he's done it, the kind of the bushfires of insurrection keep kind of blazing. It takes him a lot of. long, long time to stabilize and pacify all these kind of rebellions. And he does it partly because he's a brutal and ruthless man, right? He does what needs to be done.
这是一个位于伊朗西南部的国家。所以基本上，这些是帝国的绝对核心地带。这些是所谓的伊朗据点。显然，在这些伊朗据点中，他们将大流士视为非法国王。他花了两年时间进行绝望的战斗才镇压了这些叛乱。即使在他做到之后，叛乱的火苗仍在不断燃烧。他花了很长、很长的时间才稳定并平息所有这些叛乱。他之所以能做到，部分原因是他是一个残忍而无情的人，对吧？他做了必须做的事。
Yes. You know, he's a serious person to use that or favorite terminology. Yes, you mess with Darius and he will kill you and he will kill you very horribly. So the rebels against Darius's rule are dispatched with very salutary displays of hideous violence. So in Persia, the rebellious aristocrats there are impaled on an immense forest of stakes. I mean, kind of spreading for miles and miles. And actually, these stakes were placed on the very place where the Shah of Iran in 1971 would hold his party. And I think that's something that perhaps the Shah of Iran didn't major on. With his caviar from Maxims or whatever
是的。你知道，他是一个严肃的人，用那个我们最喜欢的术语来说。是的，你惹大流士，他就会杀了你，而且会以非常可怕的方式杀了你。所以反抗大流士统治的叛军被处以令人震惊的暴力展示。在波斯，那里的叛乱贵族被钉在巨大的木桩森林上。我的意思是，延伸了数英里。实际上，这些木桩就放置在1971年伊朗沙阿举办派对的地方。我想这可能是伊朗沙阿没有重点强调的事情。带着他从马克西姆餐厅买来的鱼子酱或无论什么
it was. Yeah, and Princess Anne. Princess Anne, yeah. She'd, she'd, she'd, wouldn't take any prisoners, though, to be able. She definitely impale rebels, I think. She absolutely would. And what about this other guy, this guy from media? So the meads come up with a pretender of their own, don't they? And he doesn't come to a very happy end at all. So the great capital of media is this place called Egbatana, which according to Herodotus is a bit like Minas Tirith. It's kind of rings of fortifications around a central stronghold. And each wall is a beautiful, different colour. And this is where this Median aristocrat has set himself up as a kind of independent king. Darius captures him, has his nose cut off, his tongue, his ears. He's then blinded in one eye so that he can witness
那是。是的，还有安妮公主。安妮公主，是的。她，她，她，虽然不会抓俘虏。她绝对会把叛军钉死在木桩上，我想。她绝对会。那米底的那个家伙呢？所以米底人提出了他们自己的伪装者，不是吗？他的下场可不太好。所以米底的伟大首都是埃克巴坦那，根据希罗多德的说法，它有点像米那斯提力斯。它是一圈圈的防御工事围绕着一个中央堡垒。每一面墙都是美丽的、不同的颜色。这就是这位米底贵族将自己建立为某种独立国王的地方。大流士抓住了他，割掉了他的鼻子、舌头、耳朵。然后他的一只眼睛被弄瞎，这样他就可以目睹
all his supporters being impaled around him. He's then chained before the gates of Epitana, where everyone could see him. And then, of course, he too is impaled. And to be impaled is a really hideous death. I mean, it can take days, sharp spike into your bowels. A very skilled impaler will impale you in such a way that none of your vital organs are pierced so that you would just, you just sort of sit there, as it were, for hours or days. It's time while people came and looked at you. I mean, I think that's a terrible way to die, frankly. Yeah, and the person's the masters of the protracted death. So they also have a hideous one where they kind of lock a, a bloke who's been covered in honey, insider, you know, with the hands and the feet sticking out
他所有的支持者都被钉在他周围的木桩上。然后他被锁在埃克巴坦那的城门前，每个人都能看到他。然后，当然，他也同样被钉在木桩上。被钉在木桩上是一种非常可怕的死法。我的意思是，这可能需要几天时间，尖锐的钉子刺入你的肠子。一个非常熟练的行刑者会以这样一种方式钉你，即你的重要器官都不会被刺穿，这样你就可以坐在那里，持续数小时或数天。这是人们过来看着你的时间。我的意思是，我认为那是一种可怕的死法，坦率地说。是的，波斯人是长期死亡的大师。所以他们还有一种可怕的方法，他们把一个涂满蜂蜜的家伙锁在里面，你知道，手脚伸出来，
of two barges that have been placed over him. And basically, he just get, you know, you get eaten by maggots and flies, lay eggs in your eyes. And I mean, just horrible, horrible. Different times. Let's face it, DeRais is doing what has to be done. It's the kind of thing I think that would garner respect from the Sandbrook political position. I was bad to say, I respect it. I don't necessarily prove it, but I respect it.
放在他身上的两艘驳船里。基本上，你只是，你知道，你被蛆虫吃掉，苍蝇在你眼睛里产卵。我的意思是，太可怕了，太可怕了。不同的时代。让我们面对现实吧，大流士正在做必须做的事。我认为这是一种会赢得桑德布鲁克政治立场尊重的事情。我本来想说，我尊重它。我不一定赞同，但我尊重它。
I know your ways and means. So that's, the Persians crushed, the median rebels crushed. There are still the Elamites. And what is, I mean, it's an incredibly obscure period of history, the Elamite rebellion. But I would argue that it's actually one of the most innovative episodes in world history. And it marks Darius out as a very consequential king, kind of almost up there with Constantine or Abdul Malik, the great Islamic Caliph. Because the Elamites keep rebelling. Darius keeps crushing them and they keep rebelling again.
我知道你的方式和手段。所以，波斯人被镇压了，米底叛军被镇压了。还有埃兰人。我的意思是，这是一个极其晦涩的历史时期，埃兰叛乱。但我认为这实际上是世界历史上最具创新性的事件之一。它标志着大流士是一位非常有影响力的国王，几乎可以与君士坦丁或伟大的伊斯兰哈里发阿卜杜勒·马利克相提并论。因为埃兰人不断叛乱。大流士不断镇压他们，而他们又不断叛乱。
And so what he does is to weaponize a very distinctively Persian understanding of the supernatural. Because the Persians, they're not like most other people in the Near East at this time, because they have essentially moralized the entire universe. They see the universe as being governed by a perpetual cosmic war between truth, which they call Arta, and the lie, this universal lie, which they call Drauga. And Darius casts himself as the agent of Arta, which means order as well as truth. To the Persians, order and truth are kind of synonymous. thing. And his genius is to brand his enemies as agents of Drauga, of the lie, and more specifically as agents of davers who are kind of demons, false gods. And this is why Darius had condemned the false bardia as a liar king. He is not just someone who had been telling fibs. He's someone who
所以他所做的是将一种非常独特的波斯超自然理解武器化。因为波斯人，他们不像当时近东的大多数其他人，因为他们本质上将整个宇宙道德化了。他们认为宇宙是由真理（他们称之为“阿塔”）与普遍的谎言（他们称之为“德劳加”）之间永恒的宇宙战争所统治的。大流士将自己塑造为“阿塔”的代理人，这意味着秩序以及真理。对波斯人来说，秩序和真理是同义词。他的天才之处在于将他的敌人标记为“德劳加”（谎言）的代理人，更具体地说是“达瓦”（恶魔、假神）的代理人。这就是为什么大流士谴责假巴尔迪亚为谎言之王。他不仅仅是一个撒谎的人。他是一个
has been in hock to all that is darkest and most malign in the cosmos. So in 520, when the Elamites launch yet another rebellion. I think losing track slightly, I think maybe it's their third or fourth. Darius takes this really, really momentous step. He tells his army, and no one had ever done this before in history, that if they go to war against the Elamites, they can expect, and I quote, divine blessings, both in their lives and after death. And the reason for this is because the Elamites are, and I quote, faithless. They are offenders, not just against Darius himself, but against the truth and order of the cosmos and of the god of light and truth, Ahura Mazda, who is the god of this truth. And it's hard to over-emphasize how mad this is, because at this period, no one had really
一直与宇宙中最黑暗、最恶毒的事物勾结的人。所以，在公元前520年，当埃兰人发动又一次叛乱时。我想我有点记不清了，我想可能是他们的第三或第四次。大流士采取了这一非常、非常重大的步骤。他告诉他的军队，历史上从来没有人这样做过，如果他们对埃兰人发动战争，他们可以期待，我引用，“神圣的祝福，无论是在他们的生活中还是死后。”原因在于埃兰人是，我引用，“背信弃义的”。他们是冒犯者，不仅是对大流士本人，而且是对宇宙的真理和秩序，以及真理与光明之神阿胡拉·马兹达（他是这种真理的神）的冒犯。很难过分强调这有多疯狂，因为在这一时期，没有人真正
thought that a people who neglect the worship of a god should be kind of punished for, you know, it's not their God, it doesn't matter. Why would they be worshipping it? But Darius is kind of instituting this notion that even though the Elamites don't necessarily worship Ahura Master, they should still be punished for it. And you can see there that this is a really, really portentous innovation. And because it contains the seeds of some quite radical notions, which will have a very long afterlife. So basically the idea that foreign rebels can be condemned as rebels against a God that they don't worship. The warriors can be promised not just riches in this life, but, you know, all kinds of benefits in paradise. And that conquest in the name of a god.
认为一个忽视崇拜神的人应该受到惩罚，你知道，那不是他们的神，没关系。他们为什么要崇拜它？但大流士正在建立这样一种观念，即即使埃兰人不一定崇拜阿胡拉·马兹达，他们仍然应该因此受到惩罚。你可以看到，这是一个非常、非常具有预兆性的创新。因为它包含了一些相当激进的观念的种子，这些观念将会有很长的后世。所以基本上，外国叛军可以被谴责为反抗他们不崇拜的神的叛军。战士们可以被承诺不仅在今生获得财富，而且在天堂获得各种好处。而以神的名义进行的征服，
or of a kind of moral truth or order can be cast as a moral duty. And these are, you know, these are going to, these are going to have a very, very long life. Yeah, ideas that have never gone away, Tom. Correct. So it's, I think, a very kind of crucial moment. And it helps Darius secure his rule, crush his enemies, this combination of kind of militant devotion to notions of truth and a readiness to impale people and kind of mutilate them. And it's, you know, it's a great combination, very effective.
或者以某种道德真理或秩序的名义进行的征服，可以被视为一种道德义务。这些，你知道，这些将会有很长、很长的生命。是的，从未消失的观念，汤姆。没错。所以，我认为这是一个非常关键的时刻。它帮助大流士巩固了他的统治，镇压了他的敌人，这种对真理观念的激进奉献与随时准备将人钉在木桩上并残害他们的准备相结合。而且，你知道，这是一个伟大的组合，非常有效。
And it helps him to set the Persian Empire on foundations that are so secure that it will endure pretty much in a state of peace. I mean, you know, give or take the old rebellion or whatever for about two centuries until it ends up conquered by Alexander. And he's not just, I mean, he's not just fearsome and he's not just good at weaponising religion. I mean, he's also just very good at running empires, right? He does what needs to be done. He, the administrative legwork, you know, he gets up and he does his. paperwork basically. Yeah, so we've compared him to Constantine, but you could also compare him to Augustus. I mean, he's that significant. He's that able. And he found this great palace to serve him
它帮助他将波斯帝国建立在如此稳固的基础上，以至于它将基本上处于和平状态。我的意思是，你知道，除了偶尔的叛乱或什么的，大约两个世纪，直到它最终被亚历山大征服。而且他不仅仅是，我的意思是，他不仅仅是可怕，他不仅仅擅长将宗教武器化。我的意思是，他也非常擅长管理帝国，对吧？他做了必须做的事。他，行政上的腿部工作，你知道，他起床并做了他的文书工作，基本上。是的，我们将他与君士坦丁进行了比较，但你也可以将他与奥古斯都进行比较。我的意思是，他就是那么重要。他就是那么有能力。他建立了这座伟大的宫殿来服务他，
as his nerve centre, as his powerhouse, and also as the showcase for his power. And the Persians call it parsa, so basically Persia, and the Greeks will call it Persepolis. And this is the site where the Persian rebels had been impaled. You know, this is where the Shah and due course will have his great party. And Persepolis becomes the focus of an immense network of precisely organized tribute that spans the entire empire. And Cyrus and Cambyses, they hadn't really been bothered with this kind of thing. But Darius is, you know, he has the brain of an accountant. And actually, the Persian nobles mock him behind his back as a shopkeeper. But it is precisely this mastery of tribute and of fiscal policy and so on,
作为他的神经中枢，作为他的动力源，也作为他权力的展示。波斯人称之为“帕萨”，基本上就是波斯，而希腊人称之为“波斯波利斯”。这就是波斯叛军被钉在木桩上的地方。你知道，这就是沙阿在适当的时候将举办他的盛大派对的地方。波斯波利斯成为了跨越整个帝国的精确组织贡品网络的焦点。居鲁士和冈比西斯，他们并没有真正被这种事情所困扰。但大流士，你知道，他有一个会计的大脑。实际上，波斯贵族在背后嘲笑他是个店主。但正是这种对贡品和财政政策等的掌握，
that actually is at least as important as his talents as a general. You know, it's a combination of knowing how to conquer people and then knowing how to screw the money out of them so that they don't rebel. But the real genius is that he allies that with this sort of moral ideological vision, isn't it? That you basically combine somebody who's brilliant
实际上至少和他作为将军的才能一样重要。你知道，这是知道如何征服人们，然后知道如何从他们身上榨取钱财，使他们不叛乱的结合。但真正的天才在于他将这一点与这种道德意识形态愿景结合起来，不是吗？你基本上结合了一个擅长
at actually extracting money from people and who's, you're a great practical empire builder with somebody who creates an ideological justification for empire, where his empire is a reflection of divine order, and to challenge it makes you a rebel against harmony and order and truth and all that is divinely sanctioned and all that is good in this world. So you get conquered by the Persians, you get told you've got to give enormous amounts of tribute, and then you get told that if you're going to rebel, then you know, you're in rebellion against truth and order, and that this truth and order spans the entire
从人们身上提取金钱的人，以及一个伟大的实际帝国建设者，与一个为帝国创造意识形态辩护的人，他的帝国是神圣秩序的反映，挑战它使你成为反抗和谐、秩序、真理以及所有神圣认可的事物和世界上所有美好事物的人。所以你被波斯人征服了，你被告知你必须缴纳巨额贡品，然后你被告知如果你要叛乱，那么，你知道，你是在反抗真理和秩序，而这种真理和秩序跨越了整个
cosmos. And so it enables Darius, who I think is clearly not a very pleasant man, to cast himself as a kind of friendly uncle. So this is one of his proclamations. I am the kind of man who is a friend to the right, who frowns upon the wrong, who has no wish to see the weak oppressed by the strong. And so he's basically saying that if you submit to me, it's not a humiliation, it's not a conquest, you are blessed. You've been absorbed into the eternal order of the cosmos. And what this means in turn, of course, is that if the Empire of the Persians is to be cast as a kind of earthly reflection of the divine order of the cosmos, then it means that all those peoples who are not in the empire, who lurk on the fringes of it, that they belong to the dimensions of the lie,
宇宙。所以它使大流士，我认为他显然不是一个非常讨人喜欢的人，能够将自己塑造为一个友好的叔叔。所以这是他的公告之一：“我是那种对正义友好，对错误皱眉，不希望看到弱者被强者压迫的人。”所以他基本上是在说，如果你服从我，这不是一种羞辱，这不是一种征服，你是被祝福的。你已经被吸收到宇宙的永恒秩序中了。当然，这意味着，如果波斯帝国被塑造为宇宙神圣秩序的某种世俗反映，那么这意味着所有那些不在帝国之内，潜伏在帝国边缘的人民，他们属于谎言的维度，
that they are essentially worshippers of demons. So is the implication that the Persian Empire, you know, is it absolutely explicit that the Persian empire will effectively become universal? because if this is about divine order, surely there can be nowhere on earth that is beyond the reach of the divine order, right? That's why he's the king of kings. It's why he's the king of lands. It's kind of implicit in those titles. Yeah, it is a kind of universalizing dream. And that means that Darius feels he has the perfect right to go around attacking people beyond the frontiers of the empire. And high on the list of people that he wants to attack are people that the Greeks call the Skidians, that the Persian is called the Saka, and these are horsemen who lurk in the steps to the north
他们本质上是恶魔的崇拜者。那么暗示是波斯帝国，你知道，是否绝对明确波斯帝国将有效地变得普遍？因为如果这是关于神圣秩序，肯定地球上没有任何地方可以超出神圣秩序的范围，对吧？这就是为什么他是万王之王。这就是为什么他是万国之王。这些头衔中隐含着这一点。是的，这是一种普遍化的梦想。这意味着大流士觉得他有完美的权利去攻击帝国边境之外的人。在他想要攻击的人名单上，名列前茅的是希腊人称为“斯基泰人”，波斯人称为“萨卡人”的人，这些是潜伏在北部草原的骑兵
of the Persian Empire. They have tall, pointy hats, they love a bong, they're incredibly proficient horsemen, and Daraas decides it's time to pacify them to bring truth and order to the steplands. And so he decides that he's going to attack them in the west. So he arrives in Sardis with an enormous expedition, and Sardis, of course, we say, said is the capital of the Lidian Kings, and it's now the seat of the Satrap, the provincial governor of Anatolia. And this is a guy called Artafernes, who is Darius's brother. And Artifernes means literally the splendor of Arta, the splendor of truth and order. So it's a very kind of appropriate name. And Artifernes is the governor, not just of Lydia, but of the Ionian Greeks
波斯帝国。他们戴着高高的尖帽子，他们喜欢大麻烟，他们是极其精通的骑兵，大流士决定是时候安抚他们，将真理和秩序带到草原地带了。所以他决定他要在西部攻击他们。所以他带着一支庞大的远征军抵达萨迪斯，当然，萨迪斯，我们说，是吕底亚国王的首都，现在是总督，安纳托利亚省长的驻地。这是一个叫阿尔塔弗内斯的人，他是大流士的兄弟。阿尔塔弗内斯字面意思是“阿塔的辉煌”，真理和秩序的辉煌。所以这是一个非常恰当的名字。阿尔塔弗内斯不仅是吕底亚的总督，也是爱奥尼亚希腊人的总督
as well on the Aegean coast. So Darius is now kind of emerging for the first time into the kind of the Greek area. Sorry, I'm just trying to understand his sense of geography. He wants to attack the Scittians, who are basically in, where are they? Are they in Ukraine? All the kind of the steplands north of Persia. So Darius, by this point, has already attacked them beyond the Caucasus. He's launched an invasion there.
以及爱琴海沿岸的。所以大流士现在第一次进入了希腊地区。抱歉，我只是想了解他的地理感。他想攻击斯基泰人，他们基本上在，他们在哪里？他们在乌克兰吗？所有潜伏在波斯北部的草原地带。所以大流士，到这一点，已经攻击过高加索以外的他们了。他在那里发动了一次入侵。
He's kind of pacified them. Now he wants to attack the tribes who lurk kind of beyond the Black Sea. So he's going a very elaborate roundabout. routes, right? He's going to go up through the Balkans. Yes, I think he wants to expand into Europe. I think he wants to kind of to have a foothold there. I think there are all kinds of various strategic considerations. But I think he also, he hasn't really done his homework because if he had studied the
他安抚了他们。现在他想攻击潜伏在黑海以外的部落。所以他走了一条非常复杂的绕路，对吧？他要穿过巴尔干半岛。是的，我想他想扩张到欧洲。我想他想在那里有一个立足点。我想有各种各样的战略考虑。但我认为他也没有真正做好功课，因为如果他研究过
careers of Napoleon or Hitler, he would realize that launching attacks into the steplands of Ukraine and Russia beyond it is not a sensible thing to do. Do you know what? He hadn't done. He hadn't listened to our excellent. series about Charles the 12th and the Great Northern War. No, he hadn't. So anyway, so he's inside is he marches north up towards the Hellespont, which is the straits between Asia and Europe, crosses them, goes up to the Danube, builds a pontoon bridge across the Danube, and vanishes into
拿破仑或希特勒的职业生涯，他就会意识到，对乌克兰和俄罗斯以外的草原地带发动攻击不是一件明智的事情。你知道吗？他没有。他没有听我们关于查理十二世和大北方战争的精彩系列节目。不，他没有。所以无论如何，他在萨迪斯，他向北进军，前往赫勒斯滂，也就是亚洲和欧洲之间的海峡，穿过它们，到达多瑙河，在多瑙河上建造了一座浮桥，并消失在
the steplands. And unsurprisingly, the campaign proves a disaster because the Skivians on their horses adopt a scorched earth policy, as the Russians and the Ukrainians and so on will do many times in the future, and Darius finds it impossible to corner them. He's basically the first imperial invader to discover that it's not actually very easy to conquer the steplands. And meanwhile, in his rear by this pontoon bridge on the Danube, there is also danger lurking because Darius has set kind of squadrons to guard the pontoon bridge to make sure that no one attacks it. And one of the people who've been set to guard this pontoon bridge is actively treacherous, is actively plotting the ruin and destruction of Darius. So these guards
草原。不出所料，这场战役成了一场灾难，因为斯基泰人骑着马采取了焦土政策，就像俄罗斯人和乌克兰人等在未来多次所做的那样，大流士发现根本无法将他们逼入绝境。他基本上是第一个发现征服草原并非易事的帝国入侵者。与此同时，在多瑙河浮桥的后方，危险也在潜伏，因为大流士派了一些中队守卫浮桥，以确保没有人袭击它。而其中一名负责守卫浮桥的人却心怀叵测，正在积极策划大流士的毁灭。所以这些守卫
are the Greeks, the Greeks who are subject to Darius. They are the rulers of the various Ionian cities that dot the Egean Sea Board of what is now Turkey. And these rulers are what the Greeks call tyrannoy, from which we get the English word tyrant. But I think tyrant doesn't convey the right sense, essentially populist strongmen, they are Peron rather than Hitler. I would, I mean, it's kind of as better analogy. And they are pretty loyal to the Persians because the Persians keep them in power. The Persians use them as their tools to subdue kind of popular risings or whatever in these various Greek cities. However, there is one Tyrannos there, so kind of popular, strongman, who is not Ionian, and he's the ruler of a very recently founded colony,
是希腊人，受大流士统治的希腊人。他们是散布在爱琴海沿岸（今土耳其境内）各个爱奥尼亚城市的统治者。这些统治者就是希腊人所说的“僭主”（tyrannos），这也是英语单词“暴君”（tyrant）的词源。但我认为“暴君”这个词并不能传达准确的含义，他们本质上是民粹主义的强人，与其说是希特勒，不如说是庇隆。我的意思是，这是一种更好的类比。他们对波斯人相当忠诚，因为波斯人维持着他们的权力。波斯人利用他们作为工具，镇压这些希腊城市中可能出现的民众起义。然而，那里有一位僭主，也就是那种民粹强人，他不是爱奥尼亚人，他是最近建立的一个殖民地的统治者，
and he's an aristocrat from a city on the far western side of the Aegean in mainland Greece, and this city is Athens. And the name of this Tyrannos is Miltaiades, and he is very able, he's very ruthless, and he's ambitious, I would say, to the point of overreach. And he had sailed from Athens to what the ancients called the Thracian Chersenese, which is the thin peninsula which forms the European side of the Hellespont and today is called Gallipoli. Yeah, we'll be hearing a bit more about Gallipoli in a few weeks. Yeah, in a few weeks' time. So Miltaieties, he set up this colony on the Thracian Chersinese, aka Gallipoli.
他是一位来自爱琴海最西端、希腊本土的贵族，这座城市就是雅典。这位僭主的名字叫米尔提阿德斯，他非常有能力，非常冷酷，而且野心勃勃，我认为他甚至到了狂妄的地步。他从雅典航行到了古人所说的“色雷斯切索尼苏斯”，也就是赫勒斯滂海峡欧洲一侧的狭长半岛，今天被称为加里波利。是的，几周后我们会更多地听到关于加里波利的消息。是的，几周后。所以米尔提阿德斯在色雷斯切索尼苏斯，也就是加里波利，建立了这个殖民地。
And he's done it partly because the Hellespont is really, really important to Athens. Athens is dependent for its food supply on grain from the Chersinese and also from the Crimea. through, so the Black Sea. But I think he's also done it because he's a bit of a lone wolf. He enjoys the exercise of power. And this is why he rules the Chersenese, not as a Democrat or anything like that, but as an out and out, strong man. He has a 500th strong bodyguard. He's married into the local aristocracy. He's been busy throwing his weight around. And that's why he's infuriated that Darius has turned up, made him submit, and kind of ruined his fun to an extent. And so he comes up with this cunning plan, why don't we just cut the pontoon bridge and leave the Persians stranded
他这样做部分是因为赫勒斯滂海峡对雅典来说实在太重要了。雅典的粮食供应依赖于切索尼苏斯和克里米亚的谷物，这些谷物通过黑海运来。但我认为他这样做也是因为他有点独来独往。他享受权力的行使。这就是为什么他统治切索尼苏斯时，不是以民主派或类似身份，而是作为一个彻头彻尾的强人。他有五百人的精锐卫队。他与当地贵族联姻。他一直忙于炫耀自己的势力。这就是为什么大流士的出现让他感到愤怒，大流士让他屈服，在某种程度上毁了他的兴致。于是他想出了一个狡猾的计划：我们为什么不直接切断浮桥，把波斯人困在
on the Northern Bank? You know, it's a kind of brilliant idea. But high risk, right? I mean, the retribution of the Persians would be swift and merciless. And the other strong men, the Ionian strong men, they're not going to go for this, are they? Well, no, because, to quote Herodotus, there was not one of them, but he owed his position as Tyrannos to Darius. So in other words, they are, you know, they're the kind of the Vichy type rulers of the Greeks. You don't want to go attacking your your sponsor. And there's one guy in particular, one Ionian Tyrannos who particularly presses this. And this is a man called Histeas. And Histeas is the ruler of the most powerful of all the various Ionian cities. It's the largest, it's the largest, it's the most sophisticated
北岸呢？你知道，这真是一个绝妙的主意。但风险很高，对吧？我的意思是，波斯人的报复将是迅速而无情的。而其他的强人，那些爱奥尼亚强人，他们不会同意的，对吧？嗯，不会，因为引用希罗多德的话说，他们之中没有一个人不是靠大流士才保住僭主地位的。换句话说，他们是希腊人中的“维希政府”式统治者。你不会想去攻击你的赞助人。有一个人特别坚持这一点，他是一位爱奥尼亚僭主，名叫希斯提亚埃乌斯。希斯提亚埃乌斯是所有爱奥尼亚城市中最强大的一座的统治者。它是最大、最先进的
of the Ionian cities. And this is a place called Miletus. And it has four great harbors. full of shipping from across the Mediterranean, from across the Black Sea. It's the birthplace of philosophy. It's the birthplace of history. It's the birthplace of what ultimately one might call science. I mean, it's an absolute intellectual powerhouse. And it is praised as the glory of Ionia. And Hystias does not want to risk the prosperity and glory and wealth of his city. And so he essentially crushes Milaides' proposal. Darius returns from his abortive attack on the Skivians. He crosses the pontoon. And his dais is rewarded for his loyalty with splendid gifts, grants of land, the favour of the king of kings. And among the grants of land that his deus gets is a region of
爱奥尼亚城市。这个地方叫米利都。它有四个大港口，满载着来自地中海和黑海各地的船只。它是哲学的发源地。它是历史的发源地。它是最终可能被称为科学的发源地。我的意思是，它是一个绝对的智力中心。它被誉为爱奥尼亚的荣耀。希斯提亚埃乌斯不想拿他城市的繁荣、荣耀和财富去冒险。所以他基本上粉碎了米尔提阿德斯的提议。大流士从对斯基泰人的失败进攻中撤回。他穿过了浮桥。希斯提亚埃乌斯因其忠诚而获得了丰厚的赏赐，包括土地赠予和万王之王的青睐。在希斯提亚埃乌斯获得的土地中，有一片是
Thrace that Darius had just recently conquered. And this is a place called Mirkenus. And Mikinas has silver mines and it has forests. And forests are obviously useful for building a fleet. And I think the ambition of Histeas is to exploit the favour of Darius and the backing of the Persian governor that Hestheus can enjoy. To build a kind of semi-independent power base for himself in the Aegean. You know, he will remain loyal to the Persians in Miletus. But if he can establish, you know, a kind of, you know, Saab Empire in the Aegean in Thrace,
大流士最近刚刚征服的色雷斯地区。这个地方叫米尔基努斯。米尔基努斯有银矿，也有森林。森林显然对建造舰队很有用。我认为希斯提亚埃乌斯的野心是利用大流士的青睐和波斯总督的支持，在爱琴海为自己建立一个半独立的权力基地。你知道，他在米利都会保持对波斯人的忠诚。但如果他能在爱琴海的色雷斯建立一个属于自己的“萨博帝国”，
so the northern coastline of the Aegean, you know, that'd be brilliant. Why not? That'd be great. But that doesn't work out, right? Because he ends up with an unexpected promotion. It does. And I think possibly because the Persians are a little bit twitchy about this, you know, it's a good way to stop his regional ambitions,
也就是爱琴海的北海岸，那该多棒啊。为什么不呢？那太好了。但这并没有成功，对吧？因为他最终得到了一次意想不到的“升迁”。确实。而且我认为可能是因为波斯人对此有点紧张，你知道，这是一种阻止他区域野心的好方法，
which is essentially is to kick him upstairs. So he gets promoted to the rank of royal table companion. So that means he has to leave Miletus and head to Persia and kind of hang out in Persepolis and Sousa, the other great palace complex that Darius has. And it's essentially a kind of gilded cage because he enjoys tremendous, you know, wealth and all of that, the favour of the king. But he's a long way from home. He can't kind of build this empire that he'd been hoping to do.
那就是把他“明升暗降”。所以他被提升为皇家宴席侍从。这意味着他必须离开米利都，前往波斯，在大流士的另一个伟大宫殿群波斯波利斯和苏萨待着。这本质上是一个镀金的笼子，因为他享受着巨大的财富和国王的青睐。但他离家太远了。他无法建立他所希望建立的那个帝国。
However, all is not lost for his deers because his family retains its rule. of Miletus. So his replacement as Tyrannos is his nephew and son-in-law, a guy called Aristagoras. And Aristagoras is very ambitious, very wily, very proactive. So a chip off the old block. And Aristagoras has essentially brought into this dream of a kind of family empire in the Aegean that he's inherited from his uncle. He's very keen to do that. He is also aware that there are all kinds of social tensions in Miletus itself, that there are conspiracies, that there are whisperings, that there are plots to topple the tyranny and introduce a democracy. So these social tensions, you know, he feels like he's essentially sitting on the edge of a volcano. And that's another
然而，希斯提亚埃乌斯并没有失去一切，因为他的家族保留了对米利都的统治。他作为僭主的继任者是他的侄子兼女婿，一个叫阿里斯塔哥拉斯的人。阿里斯塔哥拉斯非常有野心，非常狡猾，非常积极主动。真是有其叔必有其侄。阿里斯塔哥拉斯基本上接受了他从叔叔那里继承的在爱琴海建立家族帝国的梦想。他非常热衷于此。他也意识到米利都本身存在各种社会紧张局势，有阴谋，有流言，有推翻僭主统治并引入民主制的密谋。所以这些社会紧张局势，让他感觉自己就像坐在火山口上。这也是另一个
incentive to try and go out into the Aegean and kind of carve out a small empire for himself, because that would then generate more wealth, which would enable him to kind of keep the lid on this pressure cooker. And so he cooks up what's the world. What's the world. seems to him a brilliant plan. And this plan is designed to boost his dynasty's power, to consolidate his relations with the Persians, and thereby to keep agitation for a democracy and Miletus firmly in check. And the plan is he will lead an expedition against the island of Naxos, which lies in the middle of the Aegean. So it's a kind of stepping stone between what's now the Turkish coastline of the Aegean and mainland Greece. And you could see
激励他去爱琴海开辟一个小帝国的动力，因为那会产生更多的财富，使他能够压制住这个高压锅。于是他想出了一个在他看来绝妙的计划。这个计划旨在提升他家族的权力，巩固他与波斯人的关系，从而将米利都对民主的煽动牢牢控制住。计划是他将领导一次针对爱琴海中部纳克索斯岛的远征。所以它就像是现在土耳其爱琴海海岸线和希腊本土之间的一块垫脚石。你可以看出
the appeal of that to the Persians, if they ever want to launch an attack on mainland Greece, Naxus would be very useful to them. And so Aristagoras goes to Artifernes. So Artifernes, to remind people, it's the Persian governor of Sardis. He is to arise his brother, isn't he? Yes. And his name means the splendor of Arta. So anyone getting muddled up between Aristagoras and Artafernes, if it's got Arter in it, it's a Persian. Okay, perfect. So Artafernes, the governor says, yeah, all right. Okay, fair enough. I'll need to check it with my brother, so he checks with Darius, and Darius says, yeah, okay, why not? And so Aristagoras is able to go to launch an expedition with the deployment of 200 ships
这对波斯人的吸引力，如果他们想对希腊本土发动进攻，纳克索斯对他们将非常有用。于是阿里斯塔哥拉斯去找阿尔塔弗涅斯。提醒一下大家，阿尔塔弗涅斯是萨尔迪斯的波斯总督。他是大流士的兄弟，对吧？是的。他的名字意为“阿尔塔的辉煌”。所以如果有人把阿里斯塔哥拉斯和阿尔塔弗涅斯搞混了，只要名字里有“阿尔塔”的，就是波斯人。好的，太完美了。所以总督阿尔塔弗涅斯说，好吧，没问题。我需要和我兄弟确认一下，于是他咨询了大流士，大流士说，好吧，为什么不呢？于是阿里斯塔哥拉斯得以发动了一次远征，部署了200艘船只，
that have been given to him by the Persians for the expedition. And he's accompanied by Persian Admiral called Megabetes, basically to kind of keep an eye on Aristagoras. And he's Artifern his cousin, so it's, again, all very much being kept in the family. And so Megabaties and Aristagoras set sail with these 200 ships. for Naxas in 499. But it's an absolute disaster. The main city of Naxos is put under siege
这些船只是波斯人提供给他的。随行的还有一位名叫梅加巴特斯的波斯海军上将，基本上是为了监视阿里斯塔哥拉斯。他是阿尔塔弗涅斯的堂兄，所以这一切都是在家族内部解决的。于是梅加巴特斯和阿里斯塔哥拉斯在公元前499年带着这200艘船起航前往纳克索斯。但这绝对是一场灾难。纳克索斯的主城被围困，
and it just drags by one month, two months, three months, four months. And after four months, Aristagoras has used up all his money. The Naxians are still holding out and Megabata says, look, come on, this is hopeless.
围困持续了一个月、两个月、三个月、四个月。四个月后，阿里斯塔哥拉斯花光了所有的钱。纳克索斯人依然在坚守，梅加巴特斯说，听着，别闹了，这没希望了。
We're giving up. There's no way we're carrying on with this. You've essentially, you know, you told us this would be easy. It isn't, you know, you're in real trouble. We're heading back. And so Aristagoras, has now seemed screwed. He's skint. He's blown all his money. Maletus, meanwhile, is absolutely
我们放弃吧。我们不可能继续下去了。你基本上告诉我们这会很容易。事实并非如此，你现在有大麻烦了。我们要回去了。所以阿里斯塔哥拉斯现在看起来完蛋了。他身无分文。他花光了所有的钱。与此同时，米利都
seething with kind of revolutionary talk by this point. And of course, he's messed up his relations with the Persians. And none of this is good. And so when Megabatis gets back to Sardis and reports to Artafernes, the Persian governor, this has been a complete screw up. Artifernes decides, no good. We're going to dismiss Aristagoras. He can no longer remain as tyrant, the Tyrannos of Miletus. But Aristagoras has anticipated that this is what the Persians will do. And so he has moved fast and already abdicated his tyranny. He stood down. He said, actually, tyrannies are awful. We should have a democracy. I am a friend of the people. And what's more, let's export this revolution. I, as leader of the Milesian democracy, I urge all the other cities of Ionia to get rid of their tyrants as well, their
此时已经充斥着革命言论。当然，他搞砸了与波斯人的关系。这一切都不妙。所以当梅加巴特斯回到萨尔迪斯并向波斯总督阿尔塔弗涅斯报告说这是一次彻底的失败时，阿尔塔弗涅斯决定，不行。我们要罢免阿里斯塔哥拉斯。他不能再担任米利都的僭主了。但阿里斯塔哥拉斯预料到了波斯人会这么做。所以他行动迅速，已经放弃了他的僭主地位。他退位了。他说，其实，僭主统治太糟糕了。我们应该实行民主。我是人民的朋友。而且，让我们输出这场革命。作为米利都民主派的领袖，我敦促所有其他爱奥尼亚城市也摆脱他们的僭主，他们的
Tyrannoy. And so this is like, you know, throwing a match onto a kindling box, and we love a match thrown onto a kindling box on the rest is history. It explodes. All the other Milesian tyrannoy are expelled. Some of them get stoned to death. Those who aren't run fleeing to the Persian satrap in Sardis. And Aristagoras basically, you know, he might as well hang for a sheep as a lamb. He now proclaims a kind of general revolt against Persian rule. So he's all in. such a big call from him. He's doing this presumably because he thinks it's this or nothing. Like this is a strategy born of total desperation and despair, presumably.
僭主统治。这就像把火柴扔进引火箱一样，我们喜欢把火柴扔进引火箱，剩下的就是历史了。它爆炸了。所有其他的米利都僭主都被驱逐了。有些人被乱石砸死。那些没被杀死的逃向了萨尔迪斯的波斯总督那里。阿里斯塔哥拉斯基本上是破釜沉舟了。他现在宣布了一场针对波斯统治的全面起义。所以他孤注一掷。对他来说这是一个巨大的决定。他这样做大概是因为他认为要么成功要么毁灭。这大概是一种出于彻底绝望的策略。
And does he ever think at this point, do you reckon that he could win? Because against the greatest empire in the world, could he hope to defy it? Well, I think he has two plans. And the first of these is very cunning because he knows that the Persian fleet is not far from Miletus, and there are lots of Ionian squadrons there. He sends an officer down to the Persian fleet, and this officer is pretending to be loyal to the Persians, and this officer arrives,
你认为他在这一点上是否想过他能赢？因为面对世界上最伟大的帝国，他能指望反抗它吗？嗯，我认为他有两个计划。第一个计划非常狡猾，因为他知道波斯舰队离米利都不远，那里有很多爱奥尼亚中队。他派了一名军官去波斯舰队，这名军官假装效忠波斯人，这名军官到达后，
and he then kind of passes secret communications to all the various Ionian admirals and says, look, why don't you just upship? We'll capture all the Persian ships, and we will make off, and we'll have captured the Persian fleet. And, you know, it's a success. The entire Persian fleet is captured and sails out of the Persian harbor,
然后他向所有爱奥尼亚海军上将传递了秘密信息，说，看，为什么不直接起义呢？我们将俘获所有波斯船只，然后逃走，我们将俘获波斯舰队。而且，这是一个成功。整个波斯舰队被俘获，并驶出了波斯港口，
and goes off and becomes, you know, it's now in the hands of the rebels. So that's a promising, clever, you know, admirable step, unexpected. But also, Aristagoras is looking westwards across the Aegean, and he's thinking, well, we might be able to get support there. And so in the winter of 499, he boards a warship, and he sets sail across the Aegean for mainland Greece. And this is going to prove a very, very fateful mission, because it is going to end up drawing the infant democracy of Athens into direct conflict with the king of kings.
然后离开，现在落入了叛军手中。所以这是一个有前途、聪明、令人钦佩的步骤，出人意料。但阿里斯塔哥拉斯也在向西眺望爱琴海，他想，嗯，我们也许能在那儿得到支持。于是公元前499年冬天，他登上了一艘战舰，起航横跨爱琴海前往希腊本土。这将证明是一次非常非常关键的任务，因为它最终会将雅典这个初生的民主政体直接卷入与万王之王的冲突中。
So the Athenians are about to enter the story. Come back after the break to find out what happens. Rees knows a thing or two about great combinations. Chocolate and peanut butter, obviously. But there's more than one way to Rees's. From indulgent Rees's big cups with caramel to crunchy Reese's pieces and Reese's miniatures, There's a delicious Rises for every mood. It's the same combo you love, just with more ways to enjoy it. So, whether you're snacking, sharing, or just treating yourself, nothing else is Rises. Welcome back, everybody, to the rest is history.
所以雅典人即将登场。休息后回来看看会发生什么。瑞斯（Reese's）对伟大的组合很了解。巧克力和花生酱，显而易见。但瑞斯不仅仅有一种吃法。从令人满足的瑞斯焦糖大杯到松脆的瑞斯碎片和瑞斯迷你杯，每种心情都有美味的瑞斯。这是你喜爱的经典组合，只是有更多享受方式。所以，无论你是吃零食、分享还是犒劳自己，没有什么比得上瑞斯。欢迎回来，各位，收听《历史的余韵》。
It is the winter of 499 BC, and we are in Athens. So to remind people, Aristagoras, the former strongman of the city of Miletus, who has now become a born-again enthusiast for democracy, and has launched an open rebellion against the Persian Emperor Darius, the King of Kings. He has arrived in Athens and he can reasonably expect a good hearing. Athens has been the sort of champion, I suppose, of democratic enthusiasm. It has been the most radical, the most revolutionary state in the Aegean. It is the, I mean, you liken it in your notes, Tom to France in the 1790s. the kind of handmaiden of change and the spearhead of reform and all this kind of thing.
现在是公元前499年冬天，我们在雅典。提醒一下大家，阿里斯塔哥拉斯，这位米利都的前强人，现在已经成为了一名重生的民主狂热者，并对波斯皇帝大流士——万王之王——发动了公开叛乱。他已经抵达雅典，他有理由期待得到良好的回应。雅典一直是民主热情的拥护者。它是爱琴海最激进、最革命的国家。汤姆，你在笔记中把它比作1790年代的法国，是变革的帮手，是改革的先锋，诸如此类。
Yeah, because Athens, like the Ionian cities, had until very recently been subject to the rule of a tyranness of a kind of autocratic strongman. And this had been an aristocrat called Hippias. And then in 510, hippies had been expelled from the city by a great popular uprising. And three years later in 507, this radical political experiment had been introduced a democracy. So Athens is the prototype for the democratic regime that the Ionians are now dreaming of installing in their own cities. Again, a bit like the French Revolution, the revolutionary regime in France attracts anxiety from all the kind of the neighboring powers, the Austrians and the Prussians and so on, and they tried to crush it. This is what Athens's neighbors had tried to do. So Thebes, neighboring city absolutely hates the Athenians and Sparta, the great military power in the South.
是的，因为雅典和爱奥尼亚城市一样，直到最近还受制于僭主的统治，也就是某种独裁强人。那是一位名叫希庇亚斯的贵族。然后在公元前510年，希庇亚斯被一场伟大的民众起义赶出了城市。三年后的公元前507年，这种激进的政治实验被引入，建立了民主制。所以雅典是爱奥尼亚人现在梦想在自己城市中建立的民主政体的原型。同样，有点像法国大革命，法国的革命政权引起了所有邻国——奥地利人、普鲁士人等——的焦虑，他们试图粉碎它。这就是雅典的邻居们试图做的事情。所以底比斯，邻近的城市，绝对痛恨雅典人，还有斯巴达，南方的军事强国，
the Peloponnese. But amazingly, the Athenians, despite the fact that up until this point, they'd been absolutely losers as soldiers, they defeat the Thebans and even more amazingly, they see off the Spartans, kind of very Battle of Valmi style, where the French defeat the Prussians. And Herodotus writes a very famous passage about how and why the Athenians had gone from being losers to complete winners. And he writes, the Athenians, while subjects of a tire, had been no more proficient in battle than any of their neighbours, but then once liberated from tyranny, they emerged as supreme by far. Proof enough that the downtrodden, since their labours are all in the service of a master, will never willingly pull their weight, whereas free men, because they have
伯罗奔尼撒半岛。但令人惊讶的是，雅典人尽管在此之前作为士兵一直是个失败者，但他们击败了底比斯人，更令人惊讶的是，他们击退了斯巴达人，这非常像瓦尔米战役，法国人击败了普鲁士人。希罗多德写了一段非常著名的段落，关于雅典人为何以及如何从失败者变成了彻底的赢家。他写道：“雅典人在僭主统治下时，在战斗中并不比他们的任何邻居更出色，但一旦从僭主统治下解放出来，他们就变得遥遥领先。这足以证明，受压迫者因为他们的劳动都是为了主人，永远不会心甘情愿地尽力，而自由人因为他们
a stake in their own exertions, will set to them with relish. And he's articulating something there that you might see in the American Revolution or the French Revolution or whatever, this idea that once you have cast off an autocratic regime, suddenly you have the joys of freedom and you fight with more determination. And we actually did an episode on this. It's episode 334 if you want to check it out. All of which of course means that the Athenians are more likely to be open to Aristagoras's proposals. So firstly, because like the French after their own revolution, the Athenians are keen to export their democracy. You know, there's a kind of ideal. ideological drive there. And so the fact that Aristagoras, when he comes there, can frame the Ionian
在自己的努力中有利害关系，会兴致勃勃地投入其中。”他在这里阐述了一些你在美国革命或法国大革命等事件中可能会看到的东西，即一旦你摆脱了独裁政权，你突然就拥有了自由的快乐，战斗起来也更有决心。我们实际上做过一期关于这个的节目。如果你想看的话，是第334期。所有这些当然意味着雅典人更有可能对阿里斯塔哥拉斯的提议持开放态度。首先，因为像革命后的法国人一样，雅典人热衷于输出他们的民主。你知道，那里有一种意识形态的驱动力。所以，当阿里斯塔哥拉斯来到那里时，他能将爱奥尼亚
revolt as being a revolt against, you know, autocratic rule of the kind that the Athenians are thrown of. I mean, that immediately appeals to the demos, to the mass of the people in Athens. But there's another reason as well, and this is that lots of the Athenians are anxious that they might already be at war with the Persians. And the reason they're worried that they might be at war, with the Persians is because back in 507 when they'd set up their democracy and they were nervous that the Thebans and the Spartans might come and crush them, they had sent ambassadors to the Persian governor, Artifernes, in Sardis, to see if they could negotiate an alliance. And Artifernes had told them, well, you know, we're the superpower, we don't bother with alliances. It's, you know, you either
起义描述为一场针对雅典人刚刚摆脱的那种独裁统治的起义。我的意思是，这立即吸引了雅典的民众。但还有另一个原因，那就是许多雅典人担心他们可能已经与波斯人处于战争状态了。他们担心可能与波斯人开战的原因是，早在公元前507年，当他们建立民主制时，他们担心底比斯人和斯巴达人可能会来摧毁他们，于是他们派使者前往萨尔迪斯的波斯总督阿尔塔弗涅斯那里，看看能否协商结盟。阿尔塔弗涅斯告诉他们，嗯，你知道，我们是超级大国，我们不屑于结盟。要么
submit or it's nothing. Again, quite Donald Trump in their approach to diplomats. And so the Athenians thought, well, yeah, we might as well. And they had offered their submission, according to Herodotus, in the form of earth and water. You kind of make the offering of this to the Persian king. And they thought that they'd done a good job. But then they come back home, it turns out that the Thebans and Spartans have been defeated, that the democracy is fine. And so everyone in Athens says, what have you done? That's a terrible move. And the problem is, is that the Athenians have now kind of offered a formal submission to the Persians. And then he's, and then he's Hippias, the exile tyrant turns up in Sardis, and Artifernes loves a tyrant. I mean, this is what they always do. They always install tyrants to rule Greek cities. And so Artifernes sends a message to Athens saying, you should take hippiers back. This is my order as you're overlord. And of course, there's no way the Athenians are going to do this. So they've got their democracy. They've thrown the tyrant out. They don't want him back. And so they say no. And there's no response to this from Artifernes. But there is a kind of nagging anxiety that, well, perhaps the Persians will
屈服，要么什么都没有。在对待外交官的态度上，这很像唐纳德·特朗普。所以雅典人想，好吧，我们还是屈服吧。据希罗多德记载，他们以“土和水”的形式表示了屈服。你得向波斯国王献上这个。他们以为自己做得很好。但当他们回到家时，发现底比斯人和斯巴达人已经被击败了，民主制安然无恙。于是雅典的每个人都说，你们做了什么？这是一个糟糕的举动。问题在于，雅典人现在已经向波斯人正式表示了屈服。然后，被流放的僭主希庇亚斯出现在萨尔迪斯，阿尔塔弗涅斯喜欢僭主。我的意思是，他们总是这样。他们总是扶持僭主来统治希腊城市。于是阿尔塔弗涅斯给雅典发了一条信息，说：你应该接纳希庇亚斯回来。这是我作为你们宗主下的命令。当然，雅典人绝不会这样做。他们已经有了民主。他们已经把僭主赶走了。他们不想让他回来。所以他们拒绝了。阿尔塔弗涅斯对此没有回应。但有一种挥之不去的焦虑，那就是，也许波斯人会
come and punish us for this. And so I think that the arrival of Aristagoras, with his suggestion that the Athenians join the Ionian revolt, it seems to offer the Athenians a chance to get onto the front foot. And it has to be emphasized that the Athenians don't really know anything about the Persians. And also, Aristagoras is telling them, oh, the Persians are absolutely wusses. You know, they're a bunch of women. They wear trousers. Right. How can the Athenians not know about the Persians when the Persia is by far the world's most preponderant power. Greeks are pretty insular. They're pretty, I mean, they're kind of vaguely aware of it, I think, but it's not like
来惩罚我们。所以我认为阿里斯塔哥拉斯的到来，以及他建议雅典人加入爱奥尼亚起义，似乎为雅典人提供了一个占据主动权的机会。必须强调的是，雅典人对波斯人一无所知。而且，阿里斯塔哥拉斯告诉他们，哦，波斯人完全是懦夫。你知道，他们是一群女人。他们穿裤子。对。雅典人怎么可能不知道波斯人，当波斯是世界上遥遥领先的最强大力量时？希腊人相当封闭。他们相当，我的意思是，我想他们隐约意识到这一点，但这不像
they can read about the Persians on the internet. They would have contacts with the Ionian cities, presumably, which are part of the Persian orbit. Yeah, they would, but I think that they, I think they probably equate the Persians to the way that the Lydians had been. You know, they're a kind of regional overlord. They probably don't have a sense of just how vast the Persian Empire is. and how immense the resources available to the Persian king.
他们可以在互联网上阅读关于波斯人的信息。他们大概会与爱奥尼亚城市有联系，这些城市是波斯势力范围的一部分。是的，他们会有，但我认为他们可能把波斯人等同于吕底亚人的方式。你知道，他们是一种区域性的宗主。他们可能没有意识到波斯帝国有多么广阔，以及波斯国王可用的资源有多么巨大。
I mean, whatever the reason is, they decide, yeah, okay, we'll join you. And so in the spring of 498, the first ever task force sent by a democracy to attack an Iranian army. Right. Set sail across the Aegean, and it's a fleet of 20 ships. And it doesn't sail alone because there is another Greek city that falls for the blandishments of Aristagoras. And this is a place called Eretria, which is a merchant. city on the nearby island of Yuba. So if you think
我的意思是，无论原因是什么，他们决定，好吧，我们加入你们。于是公元前498年春天，第一支由民主国家派遣去攻击伊朗军队的特遣部队。对。横跨爱琴海起航，这是一支由20艘船组成的舰队。它并不孤单，因为还有另一个希腊城市被阿里斯塔哥拉斯的甜言蜜语所诱惑。这个地方叫埃雷特里亚，是一个位于附近优卑亚岛上的商业城市。所以如果你想
of the map of Greece, Attica sticking out into the Aegean, there's a kind of long, narrow island directly above the northern coast of Attica. And that's Ubea, Evia, as it's called today. And in the words of Herodotus, terrible evils would stem from these ships, both for the
希腊地图，阿提卡伸入爱琴海，在阿提卡北海岸正上方有一个长而狭窄的岛屿。那就是优卑亚岛，今天叫埃维亚岛。用希罗多德的话说，可怕的灾难将从这些船只中产生，无论是对
Greeks and the barbarians, by which Herodotus means the Persians. But at first it all goes well for the Greeks, doesn't it? I mean, they join up with the Ionians, the Athenians and the Eritreans. They march to Sardis. They, so Artifernes, who is to remind people, he is the governor, he is Darius's brother. He ends up being basically barricaded in his own acropolis in the sort of citadel. And they loot and burn the lower city of Sardis. But then do you think reality
希腊人还是对野蛮人，希罗多德指的是波斯人。但起初对希腊人来说一切都很顺利，不是吗？我的意思是，他们与爱奥尼亚人、雅典人和埃雷特里亚人会合。他们向萨尔迪斯进军。他们，所以阿尔塔弗涅斯，提醒一下大家，他是总督，是大流士的兄弟。他最终基本上被困在了自己的卫城里。他们洗劫并烧毁了萨尔迪斯的下城。但你认为现实
starts to dawn on them? The Persians might be more formidable than they had anticipated. I think it does. I think they very rapidly start to realize that they've been. written off much more that they could chew. I mean, I think the burning of the Temple of Kibberle is very unsettling for them because they are now anxious that they will draw down the wrath of the mother goddess. And so they say, well, look, we're getting back. This isn't going well at all. And they head back from Sardis to the coast. And as they're drawing near to the coast, the Athenians, get attacked by Persian cavalry, which the Athenians have never come up against before. And they're routed. and I think this is the moment when the Athenians realize actually, you know, this isn't, these aren't a bunch of women, even though they may wear trousers, these are a terrifying fighters.
开始让他们清醒了吗？波斯人可能比他们预期的更强大。我想是的。我认为他们很快就开始意识到他们已经自不量力了。我的意思是，我认为库柏勒神庙的焚毁让他们非常不安，因为他们现在担心会招致大地女神的愤怒。于是他们说，好吧，我们要回去了。这进展得一点也不顺利。他们从萨尔迪斯撤回海岸。当他们接近海岸时，雅典人遭到了波斯骑兵的攻击，这是雅典人从未遇到过的。他们被击溃了。我认为这是雅典人意识到，实际上，你知道，这不是一群女人，尽管他们可能穿裤子，但他们是可怕的战士。
And the cavalry in particular, Greece is not a land that encourages the use of cavalry, whereas the flat plateau of Iran absolutely encourages the use of cavalry. And essentially the kind of the heavy infantry that forms a Greek army hoplites they're called, people with, the hoplar, the kind of heavy kit. If they get caught in open land by Persian cavalry, they are toast. And this is pretty much what happens now. The Athenian force is very brutally savaged. Those who survive, get back to their ships. And they say, we are out of here. We're not sticking around. You know, you've, you've basically lied to us. They tell Aristagoras, and Aristagoras is kind of begging them not to go. But the Athenians say, no, we're off. And they sail back across the Aegean. And they ignore all future appeals. And I think their plan is basically
特别是骑兵，希腊不是一个鼓励使用骑兵的土地，而伊朗平坦的高原绝对鼓励使用骑兵。本质上，构成希腊军队的重步兵，被称为重装步兵，带着重装甲的人。如果他们在开阔地带被波斯骑兵抓住，他们就死定了。这基本上就是现在发生的事情。雅典军队遭到了残酷的蹂躏。幸存者回到了他们的船上。他们说，我们离开这里。我们不会留下来。你知道，你基本上对我们撒了谎。他们告诉阿里斯塔哥拉斯，阿里斯塔哥拉斯在乞求他们不要走。但雅典人说，不，我们要走了。他们横跨爱琴海航行回去。他们无视了所有未来的呼吁。我认为他们的计划基本上是
to hope that the Persians will forget all about it and they will pretend that it never happened. It's like that scene in Seinfeld where George announces that he's leaving and then realise he's made a terrible mistake and just goes back in and tries to pretend that it had never happened. I think that is basically the strategy
希望波斯人会忘记这一切，他们会假装什么都没发生过。这就像《宋飞正传》里的那一幕，乔治宣布他要离开，然后意识到他犯了一个可怕的错误，又回去试图假装什么都没发生过。我认为这基本上就是策略，
to pretend that it had never happened. And to begin with, it looks a reasonable strategy because actually the Persian focus is very much on crushing the Ionian. They're the ones who are the open rebels. And it takes them four years. And of course, when victory finally comes, it is predictably merciless.
假装什么都没发生过。起初，这看起来是一个合理的策略，因为实际上波斯人的重点在于镇压爱奥尼亚人。他们才是公开的叛军。这花了他们四年时间。当然，当胜利最终到来时，它正如预料的那样无情。
So in 494, the Ionian fleet is destroyed off an island called Larday, which is an island just outside Maletus. Maletus is stormed. Her men are slaughtered. Her women raped. Her sons castrated. Her daughters enslaved. And the survivors are then sent off from the capital. coast of the Aegean all the way into the depths of the Persian Empire to Iran, to work camps,
公元前494年，爱奥尼亚舰队在拉德岛附近被摧毁，这是一个位于米利都外的小岛。米利都被攻陷。男人被屠杀。女人被强奸。儿子被阉割。女儿被奴役。幸存者随后被从爱琴海海岸一直送到波斯帝国深处的伊朗，去劳改营，
to Harims, to whatever, to the slave markets. And as they are being led off, you know, it chained in coffels, they pass settlers coming the other way who have been granted their lands by Artafernes. And those few Malaysians who have not been deported are left to, you know, huddle up amid the blackened ruins of what had been the glory of Ionia, this great birthplace. of philosophy. So it is a devastating moment. And not just for the Ionians, but for the Athenians as well. So a tragedy is staged illustrating the destruction of Miletus, and the audience are so upset that the playwright who wrote it is fined. And it's agreed that, you know, again, let's just not talk about this. However, even after the destruction of Miletus, there are two
去后宫，去奴隶市场。当他们被带走时，你知道，戴着镣铐，他们经过了阿尔塔弗涅斯授予土地的定居者。那些没有被驱逐的米利都人被留下来，蜷缩在曾经是爱奥尼亚荣耀的废墟中，这个伟大的哲学发源地。所以这是一个毁灭性的时刻。不仅对爱奥尼亚人，对雅典人也是如此。于是上演了一部悲剧，描绘了米利都的毁灭，观众们非常难过，以至于写这部戏的剧作家被罚款。大家一致认为，好吧，我们还是别谈这个了。然而，即使在米利都毁灭之后，还有两名
Ionian rebel leaders still in the field. These did not include Aristagoras. By this point, he is dead. He had been killed back in 497 in a kind of a squalid brawl in Mirkenus, his private Thracian fiefdom. But his uncle, Hystheus, is still on the scene. So Hystheus had been, this is the guy who had been taken off to Darius's court to be, you know, his table companion. And he's a very wily cunning, untrustworthy figure, really. He was always kind of playing double games. an old fox. Yes. And when the revolt broke out, he went to Darius and said, look, I'm the guy to
爱奥尼亚叛军领袖仍在战场上。这不包括阿里斯塔哥拉斯。此时他已经死了。他于公元前497年在米尔基努斯，他私人的色雷斯封地，在一场肮脏的斗殴中被杀。但他的叔叔希斯提亚埃乌斯仍在现场。所以希斯提亚埃乌斯，就是那个被带到大流士宫廷做宴席侍从的人。他是一个非常狡猾、不可信的人物，真的。他总是玩双重游戏。一只老狐狸。是的。当起义爆发时，他去找大流士说，看，我是解决这个问题的人。我了解这些人。把我送回去。于是大流士照做了。希斯提亚埃乌斯非常冷静地出现在萨尔迪斯。阿尔塔弗涅斯已经完全看穿了他。他对他说，阿里斯塔哥拉斯可能穿了这双鞋，但你才是制造它的人。换句话说，你才是煽动这场叛乱的人。希罗多德讲了一个精彩的故事，说实际上是希斯提亚埃乌斯说服了阿里斯塔哥拉斯发动叛乱。希斯提亚埃乌斯是通过找一个奴隶，剃光他的头，在头皮上纹了一条信息。你知道，基本上，让我们起义吧，让头发长出来，然后把奴隶送到阿里斯塔哥拉斯那里。奴隶必须说，剃掉我的头。
solve this. I know these people. Send me back. And so Darius does. And his dais turns up in Sardis, very coolly. And Artifernes has entirely sussed him out. And he says to him, Aristagoras may have worn the shoe, but you were the one who made it. In other words, you are the guy who fostered this rebellion. And Herodotus tells a brilliant story about how actually it was Histeas who had persuaded Aristagoras to launch the rebellion. And Histheus had done this by getting a slave, shaving his head, to towing a message on the scalp. You know, basically, let's have a revolt, letting the hair back, and then sending the slave to Aristagoras with the met. And the slave has to say, shave my head.
所以无论这是不是真的，大多数历史学家可能认为这是一个夸张的故事，但有些人相信它。希斯提亚埃乌斯到达爱奥尼亚时，一直在玩一种非常精明的双重游戏，但非常危险，因为他不仅在爱奥尼亚人中煽动叛乱，还在阿尔塔弗涅斯自己的宫廷中煽动，因为阿尔塔弗涅斯真的很恨他。
So whether that's true or not, most historians, I think, probably think that's a tall story. but there are some who give it credence. And Hysteris, when he arrives in Iona, he's been playing a kind of very shrewd double game, but very perilous because he's fomenting rebellion, not just among the Ionians, but among Artafernes' own court, because Artafernes really hates him.
所以希斯提亚埃乌斯想，如果我能除掉阿尔塔弗涅斯，那就太棒了。但这没成功。他被俘虏了。他被带到萨尔迪斯。希斯提亚埃乌斯说，看，把我送到大流士那里。
So Hysteris thinks, if I can get rid of Artafernes, that'll be brilliant. It doesn't work out. He gets captured. He gets taken to Sardis. Histeas says, look, send me to Darius.
我能解释一切。阿尔塔弗涅斯说，没门。把他钉死在木桩上。砍下他的头。腌制起来。用冰包好。送到大流士那里。据说大流士感到非常难过，他给了这个叛军的头颅一个体面的葬礼。
I'll be able to explain everything. Artifernus says, no way. Has him impaled? Chops off his head. Has it pickled? Kind of wrapped up in ice. Sends it off to Darius. And Darius, it is said, was sufficiently upset that he gave the head of this rebel, a dignified burial.
这就是希斯提亚埃乌斯的结局。我们还剩一个人。这就是米尔提阿德斯，那个接管了现在加里波利的雅典人，对吧？所以他在爱奥尼亚起义中战斗得非常勇敢和出色。但现在起义实际上已经被镇压，包围网正在向他收紧。一支中队被派去在切索尼苏斯拦截他。他设法逃脱了。整个爱琴海都在追捕他。
That's the end of Hesdaeus. And we've got one guy left. So this is Naltiades, who was the Athenian guy who had taken over what's now Gallipoli, right? So he has fought very bravely and well in the Ionian revolt. But by now the revolt is effectively crushed and the net is closing in on him. And a squadron is sent to intercept him on the Chersenese. He manages to escape it. There's a chase all the way across the Aegean.
米尔提阿德斯在最后一刻设法到达了雅典的港口法勒鲁姆。但即使他到达雅典，他的麻烦也没有结束，因为当然，他是一位贵族，他自己也曾是一位僭主，一位强人。所以他在雅典受到相当多的怀疑。事实上，那年晚些时候，他因在切索尼苏斯的僭主行为而被起诉。然而，他被判无罪，不仅如此，他还被选入十将军委员会，在这个民主政体中，他们的角色是为雅典最高指挥官（被称为执政官，也是每年选举产生）提供建议和支持。我认为原因在于，雅典人意识到波斯的阴影正在拉长，而米尔提阿德斯是他们城市中最老练的波斯战士。虽然没人真正喜欢他，但他们认为这是一个知道自己在说什么的人。我的意思是，我们应该听听他在说什么。所以我认为米尔提阿德斯当选为这十名将军之一，向雅典的投降派、其他希腊城市以及波斯人发出了一个信号，即如果波斯人攻击雅典，雅典人将会战斗。他们不会仅仅屈服。这是一个重要的信号，因为在波斯，伟大国王的目光现在正转向遥远的蛮族西部土地。但为什么呢？因为我一直觉得波斯人如此富有、如此强大、如此重要。而雅典只是，你知道，在波斯人的
Miltides manages to reach Valerum, the harbour of Athens, just in the nick of time. But even when he arrives in Athens, his troubles aren't over because, of course, he is an aristocrat and he had been himself a Tyrannos, a a strong man. And so he's viewed with a good deal of suspicion in Athens. And in fact, later that year, he is prosecuted for his tyranny in the Chersenese. However, he is acquitted, but not only is he acquitted, but he's elected to the board of the 10 generals whose role it is in this democracy to provide advice and support to the Athenian supreme commander who's called the war Arcon and who again is kind of elected for an annual term. And the reason for this, I think, is because people in Athens are aware that the Persian shadow is lengthening and that Miltaiades is their city's
感知中，它是什么？它是一个流氓国家，一个恐怖主义国家，它在边缘地带。我想你可能会问，为什么要费心？但另一方面，为什么不呢？如果它只是一个小流氓国家，为什么不惩罚它？我的意思是，你有什么损失？嗯，我认为波斯人认为这有很好的地缘政治理由。因为如果对雅典的惩罚被推迟，那么它就有可能鼓励希腊山区荒野中出现其他类似的恐怖主义国家。我认为对波斯人来说，希腊就像9-11事件后的阿富汗对美国人一样。
most seasoned Persian fighter. And although nobody really likes him, they think this is a guy who knows what he's talking about. I mean, we should listen to what he's saying. And so I think Miltadis is election as one of these ten generals serves as a signal to everyone to would-be appeasers in Athens, to other Greek cities, and to the Persians, that the Athenians, if the Persians attack them, are going to fight. They're not just going to submit. And this is an important signal because back in Persia, the gaze of the great king is now turning on the lands of the barbarous far west. Now why though? Because my sense of this has always been that the Persians are so rich, so powerful, so important. And Athens is just, you know, it's a, to the Persian
你知道，我们需要去把这种胡闹铲除掉。但还有一个宇宙维度，我认为大流士非常认真地对待这一点，即他被阿胡拉·马兹达赋予了统治世界的权力，而雅典显然是谎言的堡垒，他们在那里崇拜恶魔，需要用火来净化，波斯人需要进入那里，恢复真理和秩序。
sensibility, what is it? It's a rogue state, a terrorist state, that it's way out there on the fringe. I suppose you might say, why bother? But then on the other hand, why not? If it's only, if it's a little rogue state, why not punish it? I mean, what do you got to lose? Well, I think that Persians think there are good geopolitical reasons for it. because if the punishment of Athens is delayed, then it risks encouraging the emergence of other similar terrorist states in the mountainous wilds of Greece. I think Greece to the Persians is what Afghanistan was to the Americans in the wake of 9-11.
你可以看到这两个概念，地缘政治的和宗教的，如果你想这样说的话。我的意思是，它们非常容易融合。它们在公元前5世纪融合在一起，就像它们在随后的历史中多次融合一样。当然，如果他们占领了雅典，它可能为征服希腊本土的其他地区提供一个基地，所有这些都意味着风暴云正在聚集。
You know, we need to go and stamp this nonsense out. But there is also this cosmic dimension, which I think Darius takes very seriously, that he's been given the rule of the world by Ahura Mazda, and Athens is patently a stronghold of the lie, and that they're worshipping Dea Eva's demons there and it needs to be purged with fire the Persians need to get in there and restore truth and order
你知道，我们需要去铲除这种荒谬的行为。但这里还有一个宇宙层面的因素，我认为大流士对此非常认真，他认为阿胡拉·马兹达赋予了他统治世界的权力，而雅典显然是谎言的堡垒，他们在那里崇拜德瓦的恶魔，必须用火来净化，波斯人需要进入那里，恢复真理和秩序。
and you can see that those two notions, the geopolitical and the kind of the religious if you want to put it like that. I mean they coalesce very readily. They coalesce in the 5th century BC as they have coalesced many, many times in subsequent history. And also, of course, if they capture Athens, it then provides a base, perhaps for the conquest of the rest of mainland Greece, all of which means that the storm clouds of
你可以看出这两个概念，即地缘政治和宗教（如果你愿意这样称呼的话），它们非常容易融合在一起。它们在公元前5世纪融合了，正如它们在随后的历史中多次融合一样。当然，如果他们占领了雅典，它或许能为征服希腊大陆的其他地区提供一个基地，而这一切都意味着风暴云正在
war are starting to gather over the Aegean. And Darius' policy is twofold. Firstly, he wants to complete the conquest of the land approaches to Greece, so that's from the Hellespont all along the northern Egean coast. And secondly, he wants to intimidate if he possibly can the various Greek cities in mainland Greece and receive their submission without actually having to fight them. So the advance from the Hellespont along the North Aegean coast, he entrusts yet again to a member of his family. This is his son-in-law, a guy called Mardonius, who is incredibly dashing, perhaps a little bit too dashing. But he knocks out Macedon. So this is the kingdom that in due course will produce Alexander the Great. But for now, the king of Macedon, who is also called
战争的阴云开始在爱琴海上空聚集。大流士的政策是双管齐下的。首先，他想完成对通往希腊陆路通道的征服，也就是从赫勒斯滂海峡一直到爱琴海北岸。其次，他想尽可能地威慑希腊本土的各个城邦，在不真正开战的情况下迫使它们臣服。因此，他再次将从赫勒斯滂海峡沿爱琴海北岸推进的任务委托给了他的家族成员。这就是他的女婿，一个叫马多尼乌斯的人，他非常英勇，也许有点过于英勇了。但他击败了马其顿。这就是后来孕育了亚历山大大帝的王国。但目前，马其顿的国王，也叫
Alexander, he goes, yeah, fine, I'm giving up. He presents earth and water to the Persian ambassadors. And this means that Persian rule now extends all the way from the Hellespont to the foothills of Mount Olympus, the mountain where the gods of the Greeks have their palace. There's only two drawbacks to this triumphal approach. The first is that Mardonius's fleet is shipwrecked off Mount Athos in the north of Greece. And Mardinus himself sustains quite a severe wound. he's kind of gone off on a dashing expedition against a mountainous tribe, and he's ended up with a rather severe wound. So that knocks him out of the immediate engagements. And then the following year after Mardonius has conquered Macedon in 492 in 491, the Persian ambassadors are sent to the cities
亚历山大，他说，好吧，我投降。他向波斯使者献上了土地和水。这意味着波斯的统治现在从赫勒斯滂海峡一直延伸到奥林匹斯山的脚下，那是希腊诸神居住的山。这种凯旋式的推进只有两个缺点。第一个是马多尼乌斯的舰队在希腊北部的阿索斯山附近遭遇海难。马多尼乌斯本人也受了重伤。他当时正进行一场针对山区部落的鲁莽远征，结果受了相当严重的伤。这使他无法参加随后的直接交战。接着，在马多尼乌斯于公元前492年征服马其顿之后，公元前491年，波斯使者被派往
of mainland Greece, and most of the Greek cities do submit. They do offer up earth and water. I guess they feel, we've got nothing to lose. I mean, we might as well play it safe. But there are other cities who don't. And there are two in particular who pointedly reject the Persian demand for submission. And the first, of course, is Athens. And here, not only are the demands of the great king dismissed, but his ambassadors are tried, convicted and put to death. And the man who instigates this legal process is Miltaiades. And the result, of course, is to ensure there is no way about.
希腊本土的各个城邦，大多数希腊城邦确实屈服了。他们确实献上了土地和水。我想他们觉得，我们没什么可失去的。我的意思是，我们最好还是稳妥行事。但也有其他城邦没有这样做。其中有两个城邦特别明确地拒绝了波斯的臣服要求。第一个当然是雅典。在这里，不仅大王的各种要求被驳回，他的使者还被审判、定罪并处死。而煽动这一法律程序的人是米尔提阿德斯。结果当然是确保了没有回头路。
now for Athens. It's fight or perish. You know, there is no other option. The second city that refuses to offer earth and water to the Persian ambassadors is Sparta, the most formidable military power in Greece. And so she cannot afford to lose face. It's very important to the maintenance of her prestige and of her kind of empire in the Peloponnese, southern Greece, that she isn't seen to submit to the demands of some distant foreigner. And the Spartans don't even bother to put the Persian ambassadors on trial. Instead, they fling them down a well and tell them, before they drown in a quiet Herodotus, if they wanted earth and water, they could find it there.
现在对雅典来说，要么战斗，要么灭亡。你知道，没有其他选择。第二个拒绝向波斯使者献上土地和水的城邦是斯巴达，希腊最强大的军事力量。因此，她不能丢脸。对于维护她在伯罗奔尼撒半岛（希腊南部）的威望和帝国地位来说，不被视为向某个遥远的外国人屈服是非常重要的。斯巴达人甚至懒得审判波斯使者。相反，他们把他们扔进了一口井里，并告诉他们，在他们淹死之前，引用希罗多德的话，如果他们想要土地和水，他们可以在那里找到。
And anyone who's seen the film 300, this is the moment where the Persians get kicked down the well and the king shouts out, this is Sparta. So two cities are standing against the Persians, and these are Athens and Sparta. and it is pretty clear now to everybody in Greece, isn't it? The Persians are, they're not going to, you know, take the slide down. They're bound to come. And sure enough, the next year, Darius says, let's go for this. You know, we're going to punish these rogue states. We're going to impose, we're going to reimpose the law of heaven, order, harmony, stability.
任何看过电影《300勇士》的人都知道，这就是波斯人被踢进井里，国王大喊“这就是斯巴达”的时刻。所以有两个城邦站出来反对波斯人，那就是雅典和斯巴达。现在希腊的每个人都很清楚，不是吗？波斯人不会就此罢休的。他们一定会来的。果然，第二年，大流士说，我们行动吧。我们要惩罚这些流氓国家。我们要强加，我们要重新强加天堂的法则、秩序、和谐与稳定。
You know, we are on the side of, we're fighting this axis of evil, which are these kind of terrorist states. Yes. and we will get loads of slaves and looted treasure as well. So it's all brilliant. Everyone's a winner. Yeah. So a huge army, powerful and well-cripped, Herodotter says, perhaps 25,000 men leaves Persia in the early months of 490,
你知道，我们站在正义的一边，我们正在打击这个邪恶轴心，也就是这些恐怖主义国家。是的。而且我们还会得到大量的奴隶和掠夺的财宝。所以这太棒了。每个人都是赢家。是的。因此，一支庞大、强大且装备精良的军队，希罗多德说大约有25000人，在公元前490年的头几个月离开了波斯，
and they're heading for the distant west. And by the summer, they have passed through the Syrian gates, and they come down into the plain of Cilicia, which is in the southeastern corner of what's now Turkey. And there they find waiting for them a great fleet of ship, Some are built as weapons of war. Some are there to serve as transport ships and horse transports. The troops and horses board these ships.
他们正向遥远的西方进发。到了夏天，他们穿过了叙利亚之门，来到了奇里乞亚平原，也就是现在土耳其的东南角。在那里，他们发现一支庞大的舰队在等着他们，有些是作为战争武器建造的，有些是作为运输船和运马船。部队和马匹登上了这些船只。
The fleet glides along the southern coast of Anatolia and then out into the Aegean. And it's under the command of two generals. And one of these is a Persian, inevitably called Artafernes. It's always so confusing ancient history. And he is the son and the namesake of the governor of Sardis. and so therefore he is the nephew of Darius. He's quite young. The effective commander is a mead called Datus.
舰队沿着安纳托利亚南海岸滑行，然后进入爱琴海。它由两名将军指挥。其中一个是波斯人，不可避免地叫阿塔弗尼斯。古代历史总是让人如此困惑。他是萨迪斯总督的儿子，同名同姓，因此他是大流士的侄子。他很年轻。实际的指挥官是一个叫达提斯的米底人。
He's been given the commission because he's a very seasoned Greek fighter. He's a veteran of the Ionian revolt. But he also has a good understanding of the Greeks. He respects their gods. He even, to a degree, speaks their language, which is kind of very unusual among the Persians. And Datus has been given very precise orders by the King of Kings. He's to conquer Naxos, so that island that Aristagoras had been defeated by, and all the other islands of the Aegean.
他之所以被委以重任，是因为他是一位经验丰富的希腊战争专家。他是伊奥尼亚起义的老兵。但他对希腊人也有很好的了解。他尊重他们的神。他甚至在某种程度上会说他们的语言，这在波斯人中是非常罕见的。万王之王给了达提斯非常明确的命令。他要征服纳克索斯，就是那个阿里斯塔格拉斯曾被击败的岛屿，以及爱琴海的所有其他岛屿。
And then he is to land in mainland Greece, and he is to reduce Athens and Eretria to slavery and bring the slaves before the king. And he proves himself the perfect man for the job. He knows how to storm Greek cities. He lands at Naxos, you know, to take an Aristagoras four months, and even then he hadn't been able to capture the city. Datus takes a city within a few days. He sacks it, he loots it, and he rounds up the inhabitants, puts them on the transport ships. They are going to be taken off as slaves back to the Persian Empire. But he also knows how to win hearts and minds.
然后他要登陆希腊本土，将雅典和埃雷特里亚沦为奴隶，并将奴隶带到国王面前。他证明了自己是这项工作的完美人选。他知道如何攻打希腊城市。他在纳克索斯登陆，你知道，阿里斯塔格拉斯花了四个月时间，即便如此也没能攻下这座城市。达提斯在几天内就拿下了这座城市。他洗劫了它，掠夺了它，并把居民围捕起来，送上运输船。他们将被作为奴隶带回波斯帝国。但他同时也知道如何赢得人心。
So very near to Naxos is the island of Delos, which the Greeks think is the birthplace of Apollo and Artemis. You know, Apollo, the radiant god of light. And Datis burns enormous amounts of incense before the altar of Apollo. And so you have the two great twin plumes of smoke, one from the burning rubble of Naxos, one from the altar of Apollo. And it sums up Persian policy to intimidate and to woo, to crush down rebellion, but to offer rewards to those who submit. Then it is onward to mainland Greece. And by late July, the Persian Armada is coming within sight of Attica. And Attica is the region that Athens control.
在纳克索斯附近是提洛岛，希腊人认为那是阿波罗和阿耳忒弥斯的出生地。你知道，阿波罗，光辉的光明之神。达提斯在阿波罗祭坛前焚烧了大量的香。于是你看到了两道巨大的双重烟柱，一道来自纳克索斯的燃烧废墟，一道来自阿波罗的祭坛。这总结了波斯的政策：威慑与拉拢，镇压叛乱，但给予那些臣服者奖励。然后继续前往希腊本土。到了七月下旬，波斯无敌舰队进入了阿提卡的视野。阿提卡是雅典控制的地区。
However, the Persian generals have decided that Athens is going to wait, and instead their fleet sails up the narrow straits that separate northern Attica from the island of Yubia, on which Eretria stands. They sail up about 30, 40 miles, and there ahead of them is the less formidable of these two cities of the lie, Eretria itself. And the Eretriens have opted not to try and oppose the Persian landing on the beaches. They've withdrawn within the city. And this proves to be a disastrous decision because inside the city, there are all kinds of various factions. One of these factions is saying, this is madness. We should try and reach an accommodation with the Persians. And so after a five-day siege, two of the aristocrats in Eretria open the gates. The Persians come in. The city is sacked. Again, the people of Eretria are rounded up. They're led on to ships. And with the flames, of the city kind of rising into the sky, the Persian fleet pulls back out and starts to glide back down the straits towards Attica. So they have the coast of northern Attica now on their
然而，波斯将军们决定雅典的事先放一放，他们的舰队转而驶向分隔阿提卡北部和优卑亚岛（埃雷特里亚所在地）的狭窄海峡。他们航行了大约30到40英里，前方就是这两个城邦中较弱的一个，埃雷特里亚本身。埃雷特里亚人选择不试图在海滩上阻止波斯登陆。他们撤退到了城内。这被证明是一个灾难性的决定，因为城内有各种各样的派系。其中一个派系说，这太疯狂了。我们应该尝试与波斯人达成和解。于是经过五天的围攻，埃雷特里亚的两名贵族打开了城门。波斯人进来了。城市被洗劫。埃雷特里亚人再次被围捕。他们被带上船。随着城市火焰升向天空，波斯舰队撤出，开始沿着海峡滑回阿提卡方向。所以他们现在把阿提卡北部的海岸线留在他们的
right-hand side as they're sailing back towards the Aegean. It's very steep, it's very rugged, and it's plain that there can't be any landing there. But the Persian Admirals know that round the headland, the perfect spot is waiting for them. And this is a bearer. in the shape of a scimitar which is sheltered from the winds. It's got a long, long, open beach, which is perfect for drawing ships up onto. You know, they can basically be parked there. And beyond it, there is a flat level plane, which of course is ideal for the operation of the Persian's strongest arm, which is their cavalry. And so this is the bay that the Persian Armada heads for and the name of this bay is Mara. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
右侧，因为他们正航行回爱琴海。那里非常陡峭，非常崎岖，很明显不可能在那里登陆。但波斯海军上将知道，绕过海角，完美的地方正在等着他们。这就是一个像弯刀一样的海湾，可以避风。它有一个长长的、开阔的海滩，非常适合把船拉上去。你知道，它们基本上可以停在那里。在它之外，是一片平坦的平原，这当然是波斯最强兵种——骑兵作战的理想场所。所以这就是波斯无敌舰队前往的海湾，这个海湾的名字叫马拉松。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。